Want to wait for the green side before I point.
Okay,
boom.
Good.
Okay.
We had some technical difficulties.
Let's try it again.
Okay.
So anyway,
brother,
welcome.
Thanks for coming here.
Thanks.
So what we were saying before,
we actually said this already,
but let's say it again because the people didn't hear it.
You,
you were one of the pioneers of standup comedy in Brazil.
Yeah,
he was a,
I started with like four or five guys.
We started doing it like 16,
17 years ago and uh,
nobody knew about stand up.
It was something that I found out when I came here to live and play basketball.
I had a scholarship to play basketball and I watched Jim Gaffigan oh wow.
And Brian Regan.
Ah,
I know those guys.
And I thought it was so weird because those guys were like,
that's,
I was questioning his,
does he call his name?
Brian Regan does heat is actually him because we used to have characters and
impersonators.
So he was kind of weird.
But at the same time,
it was interesting because I'm not a guy who those characters and I do
observations and I ride.
It was a journalism degree in journalism.
So it was interesting for me to see those guys doing comedy and I thought we
could do the same in my country.
It's so crazy that it took that long for it to get to Brazil.
You would think that because everything else,
I mean,
you guys have movies and you know,
uh,
I mean city of God,
you have action movies.
You're always,
you have so much that's so similar.
The fact that standup comedy made it there is so unusual to a,
it took a long time.
A was,
I don't know why,
but the image of a comedian speaking like with a blazer or a suit or something
was Jerry Seinfeld,
very American,
you know,
and those jokes,
did they actually connect them much with us?
Like,
Oh,
I have those buckets.
And it was something that we have bigger problems than,
oh,
I just kind of a pocket.
I pulled my band.
I was like,
he was,
it was something that I could,
we couldn't connect them much,
but when we,
when we saw there was another people doing other stuff and that was like this
huge role that we could actually explore,
that was when it become interesting for us.
So comedy in Brazil,
they would basically be like a,
like say if I was a Brazilian comedian,
I would come up with a fake name if you would.
And I would do a character.
I'll wig wig,
I'll wear a certain outfit,
outfit like a very over the top screaming.
And uh,
in that steel steel exists in Brazil.
This is like a popular fourth of the people stand up.
I'm not saying that it's for everyone.
Now I have my Netflix Bash,
shall we be?
It's becoming huge because,
uh,
we have some other options right now with the Internet.
Everything changed.
The game changed completely.
So we have,
uh,
what is good has his own space right now.
It's not only what the TV ones,
she used to watch it.
So the changed a little for,
for all of us.
So how did you start out?
Did you start out by going to music clubs or he was actually standing there,
a BDSM club.
Sadomasochist really?
I remember that there was like pictures of Cox in the back and leg of a giant.
It was a huge vaginas and we have it.
And we had that show and he was,
it wasn't good,
but is it was an experience for all of us to go on stage and try to,
to,
to show them our opinions and our jokes and some irony and sarcasm we wish,
which was something that people wasn't watching,
eh,
but then it becomes,
he becomes something huge.
We got chances to go to TV and everything else.
But at first it was difficult because people could not understand is he a
character?
Is he playing your part?
So that's why I had,
and I still have a lot of problems with the law because like I did a rape joke,
which I'm not proud of.
I'm saying it's not something that,
oh,
well I'm so over the top.
I love it in the line.
And,
but uh,
he was like,
does he,
does this guy wants people to be rated?
What is,
what is he thinking?
because with all those jokes was taken out of context and put it on newspapers
kind of killed,
uh,
he kind of killed the,
my desire to the committee of her dad as well.
Really?
Yeah,
it was,
it was difficult because he was like journalists,
journalists in the audience waiting for me to say some Shit,
put out of context and then guide like a fucking,
like billions of clicks on their website because joke I did,
that's how we,
the controversy was starting over that.
And I don't know if the same thing here.
So they knew that this was a new thing.
They,
and then so they would come to see it and then what would they criticizing it
before this he was,
he was huge.
Everybody loved it.
Then of course,
but when,
when,
when man,
when we started to have money and a TV shows and we kind of ran away out of the
underground,
I was doing shows at midnight,
like packing at three,
300 seat theater.
And midnight in Brazil.
That was my thing.
Underground is some Powell in the middle of nowhere.
But then people have this guy style into,
let me give him a chance.
So they put me on TV and I don't know where I was on TV doing the same thing.
Wow.
So the country was not that prepare for what I was doing at the time.
What kind of laws do you have in Brazil in terms of like the language of you're
allowed to use on television?
You know,
the,
I'm not saying there's like a government censorship about what you can say,
what you cannot say.
But uh,
sponsors and,
and even TV stations and the media is very sensitive about everything because
it's still a poor country.
I still a bazooka to a third world country.
So we are,
we are like,
we have a lot of people that don't understand the though,
oh this is comedy.
What,
what,
what's,
what's comedy?
So it was my duty to explain a little bit.
Wow.
Well what was standup and kind of for open a road for all of us.
That's how I felt.
So you and you said three,
three or four guys.
It's,
so who are these other guys?
They're still doing comedy in Brazil.
Yeah,
they still doing.
They still huge.
What are their names?
Uh,
Marcel Mansfield.
The illusion.
Chile or scared or feel you?
There was a small group of guys that we started doing Brazilian Portuguese.
Such a beautiful language.
I love it.
I love,
it's like a song.
It's like,
it's [inaudible].
I've been doing Jujitsu for 23 years,
so it's like,
to me that sound is like,
it's such a cool sound.
What does,
what does Brazilians say in Jersey says though?
Is there a word or something that they are still repeating that you know?
Well,
I mean,
you know Paul Ha Paul,
which is come is that fucker come,
which wouldn't come but sometimes ah,
Aha though.
Sometimes you say it like damn,
but it's come,
it's COPCO.
It's funny cause like that's like the word Shit.
Like shit could be like,
you could look at something,
go shit nailed.
That's good.
But it's shit can also be bad.
Yeah.
You know,
like fuck too.
Like fuck could be good or fuck could be bad.
Like you could stub your toe and go fuck.
Or You could,
you could see a girl with a beautiful body and go,
fuck yeah,
but Paul has the same fee had so crazy,
but it's because,
oh,
it's good.
It's like a big buff,
but then you're getting a choke boy.
Huh?
I got it.
It's the same thing.
It's exactly the same.
That's so funny.
Man.
Language is difficult,
man to speak in English.
I was,
uh,
I wasn't,
you know,
I was thinking about it,
Eh,
black people has to stop using the n word in rap songs because be,
it becomes a trap for immunity.
Karaoke.
I was singing karaoke and the end of the song,
this guy came up to me,
I was like,
don't drop the n word man.
But he was in the song,
so what should I do?
Not seem to more.
Right.
It's so that the light language is something that is,
I'm still like learning.
There is,
it's difficult,
man.
Well,
it's very tricky.
I mean it's obviously in America there's this sort of a acknowledgement that
black people were slaves for so long they are allowed to do more things and in
particular how to use that word.
Okay.
There's no other word like in terms of uh,
like a,
like a bad word about an ethnicity no.
That people use for them.
So like,
like a Puerto Rican person would never call himself a spic and like a good,
like what's up?
Like to another Puerto Rican,
it's v The n word is a very unique word.
Like there's no word really cannot say in any situation.
I could say it if I'm explaining it like this guy called that guy a nigger.
I can say that.
But even saying that people,
some people wouldn't do that.
I'm not,
I would never call someone that.
Okay.
But I will use it if I,
if I'm quoting someone or if I'm explaining the word itself because to run away
from the joke is even hotter because he'll be our knowledging that that's up for
bidding war.
So yeah,
Chris Rock had one of the greatest bits of all time.
Okay.
That there are black people and there are niggers.
This was his joke,
but even for me to say that that was a joke,
and to say it that way is dangerous and it's one of the greatest comedy routines
in the history of standup.
That's crazy.
Yeah.
But a white person could never quote that,
Joe,
you can't do the joke.
Like if you tried to do it a joke to your friend,
like you'd have to go can,
we can make it.
I'm going to be looking around.
Chris rock is so funny.
Let me tell you the bit like,
you'd have to be really careful.
I mean,
there's no way you could do the whole joke on a podcast.
It's just,
you say the word,
the n word.
Too many times people get mad at you.
That's crazy,
man.
You know,
racism is crazy.
The fact that there's still racism,
that's what's crazy.
The word is just sort of a like a,
it's m,
it's symptomatic.
It's like there's a,
there's a thing there that connects it to the feeling of racism,
even if you're not using it in a racist context.
Yes.
So for me,
I'm a,
I'm a foreigner,
so,
uh,
I was never so aware of racists.
Like I am now living in this country.
Yeah.
Brazil's,
no,
racism is very mild,
very different.
That is racism.
I cannot say that there is not racism of our studies,
but here it's like,
uh,
when there's an election they even say how the white folded and how the black
folded.
That's kind of weird because for me that's racism.
Yoda,
like dividing people more racist and it's clear on TV and sometimes they'll even
stop thinking about it.
It's like it's bought off the,
the,
the whole thing.
Well,
it's because the black community doesn't feel like they're represented and they
felt like they were represented finally when Obama became president because we
finally,
we had a black president.
But other than that,
you know,
there's a real distinction.
Like with Obama,
it was like almost universal.
He was going to get air quotes,
the black vote,
you know.
But with Trump,
I mean it's,
or with anybody else,
it's very tricky.
It's very,
it's a very different thing.
They want to make sure that their community is being represented and that their
needs are being represented.
I completely understand and I agreed that there's someone knowledgement to make
the history,
but at the same time I'm knowledging uh,
may divide kind of divides you a little bit as well.
Yes,
it does.
And it's also used as a weapon by some people that you know,
or are not,
they're not being honest.
They're just using it as a tool to divide people or to force their agenda
through or,
you know,
again,
the real problem is not the words.
The real problem is not,
the real problem is actual real racism.
That's the real problem.
It still exists.
It exists less than it did a hundred years ago and far less than it did 200
years ago.
And a hundred years from now it'll probably be almost nonexistent.
But it's a real problem.
People are tribal.
They differentiate by town.
People differentiate by what part of the country you're from.
And they certainly differentiate by nation and they differentiate by the origin
of your ancestors.
It's,
it's really stupid is what it is.
Unless you're just celebrating the differences and how interesting.
You know,
there's different food and different music and different culture and literature,
but the,
you know,
actual,
real racism.
The fact that it's still exists in 2000 and
it is crazy.
I got,
uh,
and that is the racism Brazil was,
I'm not saying that there's not racism,
more mild was there.
Interracial relationships are much more common.
If you see like a black,
a black guy with a white woman,
it's not a nobody that was going to say shit.
It's normal.
It's not something that people will go by pointing or something.
I don't think so.
But there's parts of this country where it's,
it's a real problem.
There's parts of this country where there's real racism on a black man with a
white woman is in danger and now they have to be careful if they go into the
wrong bar.
They have to be careful if they're going to the wrong place.
It's fucking crazy.
That's crazy.
Yeah,
it is crazy.
That is a,
some kind of,
uh,
it's not,
is not 100% of the time that I feel comfortable here.
There's a lot of situations that I have,
I feel that I can say the wrong thing because I don't want,
cause you don't understand the day.
Did you learn English?
I played basketball here.
Oh,
so you learn to eat in order to play?
He was,
yeah.
I will you at the time,
was he swills 1999.
I was 23 at a time of 42.
So,
uh,
it was 1999.
I play basketball here and I learned the English and that's when I got a first
time I saw stand up.
I was like,
fuck,
that's so easy.
Wow.
That was 1999.
So when you brought it over to Brazil,
when you brought over stand up,
did you guys get together and say,
hey,
let's try to do this over here.
Where can we do it?
Uh,
W I had three friends that knew about it.
It's just going to fuck a cult.
A secret cult of people who knew about stand up.
And,
uh,
we were like,
let's try it.
But the only,
the only email that we have was Seinfeld at the end of every episode.
That was the,
that was the thing for us.
That's the only reference.
I still remember that the first veto that were like talking about what we were
doing,
we were like,
oh,
so this is standup.
Uh,
no,
we'll do,
do you,
did you ever see every episode of Seinfeld at the end?
He does like under routine.
Oh,
this is what they're going to do on the theater right now.
So that's when we wanted to do it.
And uh,
and it took some time because we started in 2002,
2003 and youtube just came on 2005.
But when youtube came,
that was like a lot of people posting stand up and little like 30 minutes
comedy,
central specials.
And then we could see and that,
and he was difficult at first because of everything that I was writing,
I could see people doing on TV.
My jokes,
it was hard for me to explain to people,
this is my joke.
Like stole your jokes was not even like stealing because they didn't just joke.
Right.
It was just a joke.
How can I explain to people,
okay,
this is what I wrote.
I'm not going to do jokes that other people wrote a this is it's mine.
Yeah.
People thought I was a little crazy.
Oh,
that's funny.
Wow.
Because,
um,
you know,
I don't know if you have this anecdotes that everybody saves you have here in
America.
Okay.
We have standup where people write their own stuff and we have anecdotes.
Sure.
And that's what we had like little books with that.
And so when I say a joke,
people think that I was doing from those books.
Yeah.
There's standup comedy and then there's jokes like that.
People tell,
well we call them street jokes.
Three jokes.
Okay.
Would like to Jews walk into a bar.
That's,
those,
those jokes are so interesting because I don't know anybody who's ever written
one of those jokes.
I don't,
but,
but if you think about it,
that is a good time.
It's something that every time that I see,
like one of those good joke,
a good street joke,
I was like fuck,
I want it to be a fucking,
I want to meet to create that way.
Yeah.
But it's,
it's interesting cause there's so many of them and no one knows anyone who wrote
them.
Those,
that was one guy in Brasilia was doing those three chokes and he created like
10% of what he interesting.
But for him was like,
this is what I created.
Denied the 90% that I didn't create.
It's kind of in the same chunk.
I don't now when Seinfeld airs in Brazil,
I assume that it's translated to Portuguese is dubbed.
It's done.
And when it's dubbed as a dubbed,
well does it make sense?
No,
no,
no.
He does the jokes translated standup wise now.
Now the series of works now,
now he got much better dubbing.
Got Much better.
Oh really?
But it's crazy.
We have subtitles as well.
Like my Netflix special has subtitles here in America,
so subtitles for English.
Oh Wow.
So you do it in Portuguese.
Do you do much standup in English?
Having to send them here for her for eight months,
like all the clubs and being three Improv and a factory in and a,
but here I do it in English.
I don't even what I do on stage now it's something that I wrote leaving here
like 80% and 20% I translated for my acting Portuguese.
Wow.
And some of those jokes don't work when I translate.
And it's always a surprise.
Yeah.
Wow.
Is a surprise.
Is the culture so different,
right.
It's like what people think is funny and what they find ironic.
But Joe,
uh,
a joke is a joke man.
Yeah.
If he,
if he has a tiny,
if he,
if I now am able to do at the same pace that I do in Portuguese,
I feel comfortable doing in English.
So I feel the same thing and it's easier for me because I actually write jokes.
I have some friends that just like has some crowd work and interact with the
audience and there's a lot of physical comedy in it.
So to translate that to English is difficult.
Yeah.
I write jokes so if I translate it in a right way,
if he had,
if people understand the context,
if people understand that I'm talking about like the pregnancy off my wife and
marriage and I dunno being single and everything or maybe that he can work now.
When you,
what was it like the first time you did stand up in America?
The first time in English,
I actually have a clip on Youtube that the laugh factory bolstered.
Oh Wow.
He was,
he was very surprising.
It was very surprising because some jokes that I didn't think was that funny
worked and the ones that I was actually pretty sure that we work didn't work and
now it's so frustrating.
Completely lost men.
It was like,
is this is going to be a huge role for me and I have been doing,
this is what I'm,
this is why I'm here to stand up in English now.
What now stand up since it's been,
you know,
you said 16 years or so,
seniors in,
in Brazil.
Is it accepted now as it a normal part of the culture?
Yeah.
Have they had comedy clubs open up yet.
I have Mike on the club members.
Where is it is in some follow comedians is a 300 seat place.
Just like the Improv.
Wow is a great place I have in Brazil and there's enough local co comedy.
Yes.
Fill it up.
That's incredible.
It does not what I have like like on a Saturday I have three pack,
chose 10 and midnight back shows like I'm getting sound Paulo's huge,
huge,
huge city.
There's like 15 million people.
It's simple.
That's wow.
That's 15 million people live in simple.
It's so quick.
Only Portuguese.
Yeah.
There's no extent up in English in Brazil.
None.
Cause unfortunately that's not that many people that speaks English in Brazil.
Yeah.
I know they were trying to organize shows like jade was trying to get people to
come to Brazil to stand up and I was like,
good luck with that.
That just seems like there's,
it doesn't seem like there's enough people.
Jade opened for me in Portuguese in Brazil and she helps me a little bit at the
beginning here,
a opening San Clubs and then getting me some gigs.
She's a very good friend.
And,
uh,
if for her it was a little difficult in Portuguese.
Oh,
to translate English to Portuguese
forced because what you guys,
there's a coacher that there's a standup culture here.
If you're this freaky in a little crazy and he pee,
that's something that does not translate to another country.
You have to actually write jokes.
Yeah.
And uh,
and for her it was a little difficult because she,
she has this way of doing it,
like interacting in that she's like any few mess up award in Portuguese.
It's in English.
If you mess up a word in English,
it's kind of funny.
Oh,
he's a foreigner.
Except you.
There's this likability.
But if I mess up or any Portuguese,
you're a prick.
You don't speak Portuguese.
I speak English.
It sounds bad.
And I see,
yeah,
that makes sense.
Because America is such a melting pot.
There's so many different languages over here that someone,
well that's,
you know,
like I read something the other day,
like if you see someone and they speak broken English,
uh,
don't make fun of them.
That means they speak two languages.
Yes,
yes.
And you don't,
of course most of us don't in Portuguese is similar to Spanish.
So people who speaks Portuguese speak Spanish.
So I kind of was between languages.
That's,
that's,
that's a lot.
Well that helped Fabrizio over doom in Mexico because he's so fluent in Spanish
that,
you know,
when he was over there fighting,
they were like,
Holy Shit,
this guy speaks perfect Spanish.
She's from the same city that I am.
We should Paul Agnes here in the south.
So we kind of have some Spanish,
uh,
in the CD is close to two Argentina.
Oh,
I see.
It's kind of,
uh,
is our thing there.
Oh,
okay.
Cool.
So now when you were doing stand up and you started to get in some trouble for
bits,
a lot of trouble,
there's a lot of trouble.
How much trouble?
Yeah,
a lot of money.
I spent a lot of money really,
as long as I lost a lot of sauces,
I lost a lot of lessons because of jokes.
Really.
Lawsuits.
So like who was suing you?
Uh,
the people who fell offended.
So people in the audience,
artists.
When I make fun of a celebrity,
they would sue you.
They can,
they can sue you and they can get money out of really all the TV shows.
They can get up.
Politicians who sued you?
You know,
I got this,
uh,
this last,
so they really put me in trouble.
It was because of a singer.
It was,
she was a singer and a kind of a almost kill my career.
You actually did.
That's why I'm here.
So no,
Eh,
yeah.
I got into a huge lawsuit and it looks dumb when you explain,
oh,
it's just a singer.
But he became all this talk about freedom of speech and what comedians can say
and what they cannot say.
Are you allowed to fewer fandom.
And now there's like law schools talks about this,
the lawsuit that I had,
law school discussions,
discussions because of,
yeah,
because I made fun.
He was a shitty joke.
That's the problem.
You know,
he's not because of the losses.
I want to be sued by the good ones because I don't want to be known by a bad
joke.
Right,
right.
No,
of course.
Yeah.
It's just like I was saying this and he's just like,
you were meeting,
uh,
Eddy Miller.
If you one of the greatest comedians ever,
they think,
oh,
there's doctor Doolittle.
You don't have that right now.
This is the same thing with me.
That joke was a shitty joke.
And she was like bragging on TV and she was like doing a story on TV.
And I was the host of this huge TV show,
like the daily show,
the daily show meeting,
the view.
It was something like that.
And uh,
and in the middle of the thing,
she was shows there and my friend asked me,
oh,
she's pregnant and do you think she's still hot?
And I said,
she so hot that I would fuck her in her baby and a shitty joke,
but that was live.
It was like right on time.
Everybody laughed and there was no problem.
But next week it was this huge thing because she was like,
her husband was very influential show and uh,
her husband was managing run now do,
which was one of the biggest soccer player ever.
So there was this whole thing,
the TV show lost sponsors and they want to suspend me from the TV show because
the of a joke that I did,
she didn't tell them.
They didn't tell me to apologize at first,
but he suspended me.
So I quit the show.
They didn't know.
So you just apologize.
And I decided not to apologize because I felt that after like 10 years,
don't stand there or 12 years doing stand up.
It was important for me to like put my feet on the ground and say,
you know,
if we step back right now,
what am I,
what am I going to do in like a two years?
This is important for all of us is important for comedy.
So I lost lasel to loss movies a lot.
So what did they,
what did they rule in the lawsuit?
Like what was the ruling?
I have friend that her honor.
Honor's,
yeah,
it was something like that.
She was like,
uh,
people can sue you.
The suing is part of the democracy.
It's okay to sue you,
but to lot lose a lawsuit is that's the problem.
I lost like $150,000 or the sheet but in Brazil was 350,000 high.
So if you're a lawyer and you get $10,000 a month,
you get 10,000 leads a month.
So He's,
you don't translate money.
So I lost a lot of money but the thing has gotten me a huge headache and uh,
he was,
he was bad.
He was bad just from that one just for that one.
But you saw other lawsuits because of digital,
like a rape joke and uh,
I got like this women movement,
like trying to break,
break into my bar and break my,
the door of my comedy club and there was like,
that was a,
but the discussion
was more important than the problem itself.
I kind of find it was the discussion about freedom of speech in that was,
that was huge.
What is freedom of speech like in Brazil?
Is it the same brick?
I mean obviously we have the first amendment.
You have the first.
Do you have something that we don't,
we don't have that.
They don't,
they don't have that in Canada.
We don't have that.
I had Mike Ward on in Canada.
Do you know his story?
I know he's the guy who,
he made a joke about a sick boy.
The boy was still alive years later.
I thought it was.
And you know it was just a bad joke about this guy still being alive and can he
get his money back?
Cause like,
cause they donated money.
It's,
it's fucked up joke but it's supposed to be a fucked up joke and he's doing it
in a nightclub situation where people are drinking,
you say things that are inappropriate and that's the art form.
He got sued and he's still in the process of it right now.
And there's another case in Vancouver where these women were heckling,
they were yelling things out during the show and then the comedian went on stage
and be rated the women and the women's sued and won because a,
they were lesbians and he made some lesbian jokes about them at their own
expense.
And so then they took him to court and they won and they won what?
They want some judgment where he had to pay them.
I want to change me.
How much was it?
I want to say it was somewhere in the neighborhood of $30,000.
$30,000.
And for this gentleman,
this comedian,
uh,
I think that was a lot of money.
I don't know.
40 to $42,000.
Yeah.
That's a lot of fucking money for an opening comedian.
I mean,
he wasn't a famous guy.
So you know,
that might be two years worth for him.
Who knows?
You know,
of course,
of course.
Yeah.
I lost a lot of money.
So Canada,
similar count.
Canada does not have freedom of speech the same way the United States does.
Yeah.
That,
that's why,
uh,
I feel what I do comedy here and I feel that people get uncomfortable about a
joke or two.
That's when I get stressed.
It's like you have the fee that of saying those things.
Yes.
I have this joke that I say it's about the n word as well.
I might have said maybe I have to change my,
but I have this job that I do is like when I arrived here,
uh,
someone said to me,
you know,
don't use the n word or people are going to kick her ass.
But they never told me what the n word was.
So for the past six months,
I have been avoiding all wars with the letter n and the other big guy came up to
me and said,
can I fuck your ass?
And I was like,
maybe
when I say this jug is like I have to set up,
it's crazy because when I first did it was like a fucking thing.
Everybody got an uncomfortable.
Yeah.
But now I sat up as a misunderstanding because I'm a foreigner.
Yes and no.
I'm free to do everything.
Yes.
So I kind of,
I found a way of doing it.
He found a way in.
Yeah.
So that's,
it's crazy.
And I watched you a lot and I see a lot of people here.
I saw the other guy,
this guy,
this guy did an interview with you and he did this show in a college and uh,
he did a joke and people took him out of State Nimesh Patel.
Yeah.
That's crazy.
Because you built the freedom to do that.
Yes.
And now you're discussing if you can,
or youthful cannot solely in colleges though,
when children today,
and I want to call them children,
they do not understand the danger in suppressing free speech.
And so they think that what they're doing is by suppressing free speech and
changing the way people communicate.
What they're doing is making the world a better place.
They think they're,
they're signaling the virtue and making the world a better place at the same
time.
But it's just ignorant.
So just don't understand that you can't,
you,
you can't necessarily,
you can't control people.
And to think that by just getting upset and silencing someone,
I'm removing them from the stage at that ends the conversation.
It doesn't,
it reinforces their position.
It says,
okay,
look,
I was right about you fucking snowflakes and you little babies like you,
you can't even understand why when things are uncomfortable that it doesn't
necessarily mean it's negative.
And that like you're like try to put yourself in someone's position and see what
he's saying.
And in the Meshes Kit,
this case,
it's actually kinda funny,
first of all,
he's very open minded guy,
very progressive.
He's,
he's not in any way a racist.
And his joke was that people say that being gay is a choice.
And he said,
I know it's not a choice because I have a friend who's black and gay.
There's no way he would choose both of those things.
And it was just double up this just him being funny.
It's a funny joke and they,
they will like cut,
get the fuck off the stage.
Like what?
Come on man.
You don't think that's funny.
And it's also coming from an Indian man who I'm sure is experienced racism.
So the,
the whole thing is it's very fascinating to see young kids who are growing up in
this PC culture bubble and you don't,
and sometimes people say on this podcast that we talk about it too much.
It may be there.
Correct.
Maybe sometimes it's annoying if you're listening to your cubicle and you hear
me talking too much about this,
but it's because it's an issue that's very dear to my heart cause I understand
the dangers of not being able to communicate freely and I also and understand
what happens when if you suppress free communication,
the people that you're suppressing,
they're going to get more and more angry and radical and it just makes their
position that they feel more justified in there in perhaps even people who are
racists could perhaps be more racist or people who are angry about gay people
will become more angry about it if you suppress their ability to express
himself.
That's when borns those little movements and neo Nazi movements,
a little groups and then little blips on the web,
the deep web when discussion.
It's like when you in,
when it's for beating I think is you kind of forgive them the power that they
didn't have.
I think so.
And I think this is something that we were really just getting to understand.
Now,
you know,
I have,
I've had a few conversations about this recently with the head of Twitter and
with a,
an independent journalist Tim pool last week.
And I think what people were just starting to kind of understand,
even though everyone's uncomfortable about this,
is we're still trying to figure this out.
Social media is only 10 plus years old.
This is an incredibly new experience for us and I don't think everybody knows
exactly how to proceed.
And this idea that you could just band people and they just banned people for
life.
If they say something that makes people uncomfortable,
if they say an opinion you don't agree with,
banned them for life.
And we're saying we're experiencing that right now.
And,
uh,
we're trying to figure out what to do and how to,
how to fix this and how to mitigate it without endorsing people,
harassing people and divorcing people.
Uh,
you know,
threatening people and giving out their address and their phone number and
things along those lines.
So it's,
it's a process that we're,
we're all going through right now.
It is a learning process for the,
the,
the whole country.
But the thing that a noise annoys me a little bit is that I,
I leave it in another country and I see how things are difficult and how much
time I spent explaining to people what I was doing.
And for you guys,
it's like I was having the same problems that Lenny Bruce was having like a long
time ago.
Yes.
You guys built that to have that discussion.
It's like,
it is important because that's the way the ward uh,
evolved.
But at the same time,
he fuels old.
It feels old because you understand the history of it.
In America it feels old because a,
you already have that discussion a long time ago.
You know,
you couldn't keep having this conversation when you think that you'll finally,
if you free to say whatever you want now,
there's people trying to hold you back.
It's crazy.
Well,
it's not really effective.
See there's,
there's people that are angry about it.
I mean,
there is on social media,
there's certainly people that are being effective with it,
but in standup comedy it's,
there's blow back and push back.
But it's not very effective.
Like for the top guys,
for guys like Dave Chappelle and Bill Burr,
it's,
it actually makes their standup better because people are so tired of all this
shit.
They're so tired of PC culture.
They're so tired of being told what they should and shouldn't think is funny and
what is acceptable and not acceptable.
And you know,
there's,
there's a lot of weird shit going on right now.
Did you ever have problem with that?
Oh yeah.
Did someone ever leave your show because of a joke?
Who did it?
Oh fuck,
what was the subject?
I'm like,
God,
I don't even remember him so many times.
It's happened so many times.
Yeah.
I mean people just get angry.
They get angry and you're allowed to,
you mean it's fun?
It's,
look,
everybody has their own sensibilities and the problem,
one of the problems with standup comedy is if you go to a club to see music,
you know what kind of music going to go see?
You want to go see salsa,
they have a salsa club,
you want to go see jazz,
you want to go see rock and roll or you want to go to a rap show.
You know what you're,
you're going to see.
But if you go to see comedy,
you could see fucking Barry Manilow followed by guns and roses fall by run DMC.
I mean it's,
it's,
unless you're going to see a specific comedian,
like you're going to see Jim Gaffigan,
you don't necessarily know what the fuck you're going to see.
You go to the comedy store on sunset,
you're going to see if you get there at nine o'clock and stay til two o'clock in
the Morn,
you're going to see 10 15 different fucking comedians.
And they're all different.
And you know,
some of them are men,
some of them are women and some of them are gay and some of them were black.
And they all have different points of view and some of them you're going to
think of the best and some of them you think,
oh,
when is this guy getting offstage?
I mean that's just,
that's just part of it.
But for us,
what's really important about that is that when I worked there,
I,
I know that it's not my crowd.
There are everyone's crowd.
See,
if I go to do a show,
if I do a show somewhere and San Diego say,
and I advertise it,
the people that come,
they bought a ticket to see meets your cro.
Yes,
but if I go to the comedy store,
they might be there to see Neil Brennan or Chris Delea or whoever
chew your crowd.
Joe.
Some of them are the comedy store.
They steal your crowd.
They steal,
they steal.
We went there to watch you.
They know who you are.
If you go to maybe the middle of Utah,
they are not going to know like was great.
You'd be surprised.
Yeah.
Wiseguys comic grasp.
Shout out to Salt Lake City.
Oh yeah.
I lived in Nebraska,
so I couldn't imagine someone lived in Nebraska.
That's what I,
they gave me a scholarship to play basketball and Jesus Christ.
It wasn't that good.
I got to NCAA division two school.
Those he was,
he was crazy because I had a chance to meet the American people.
It's not that people who leaves in [inaudible] New York,
that's different.
I remember farmers farmers and I was like hanging around with black guys because
there was my people that was,
I was a foreigner.
We were minorities and they were playing basketball with me.
So I fell [inaudible] it's a completely different experience living in Nebraska.
He was,
he was,
he was awesome.
How'd you get out?
Uh,
did you walk?
I actually,
no,
I got injured.
Uh,
I got into a fight man,
and I broke my joy,
my cheekbone.
No Way.
A fight playing basketball on the court.
He was still fight a lot.
I was fucking,
I didn't,
I don't know.
I'm not proud of that age.
But I used to fight a lot.
I like to fight,
but I never knew how,
how do it,
which is crazy cause you're Brazilian.
Yeah.
And you know where,
but when an alley Tudos started,
it's where it Brazilian jujitsu started.
I always wold fights,
but the one that I lost,
I broke my cheekbone and my jaw and I had to do surgery here and the surgery
went bad.
Oh No.
Because,
uh,
it's crazy.
That's the specific,
but they don't have a doctor who does mouth and bones at the same time.
They have a neck and mouth doctor and the a dentist,
they don't have the one who does both.
This is the doctor that,
that time or at that place.
So the surgery went wrong.
I had to go back to Brazil and I had to do the surgery again.
Oh No.
And uh,
and I decided not to come back.
So this is how,
this is why this moment for me is very important.
Uh,
I never thought that I had,
my dream was to play basketball.
That's what I was dedicating my life,
uh,
for.
And uh,
I never thought that I will have a second chance in America.
And this is,
that's it.
That's the,
my second chance,
and I can mess this up.
So what made you come from Brazil to America for standup comedy?
It was all the lawsuits.
He was a little bit of the lawsuits.
I'm not saying that it was not,
but my friend,
it's like if you want to play basketball,
do you want to play in the NBA?
Right?
If you want to play soccer,
you want to go to Barcelona.
Uh,
standups is here,
man.
That's the place that you get a B.
And we never had a Brazilian standup comedian in,
in,
in here,
just like jade are the ones who were born here,
but not the ones who actually was like doing standup in Brazil and coming here.
I think it was important for me,
for all my colleagues and all my,
all the comedians in Brazil as well to start something here.
He has been a very good experience.
A little hard.
Yeah.
But it has been a lot of,
a lot of fun as well.
Now are you working over here?
Did you save up money and you live it off your money for you still have my
comedy club there.
I saved,
I saved some,
I got some money.
Yeah.
Yeah,
I lost some of those losses.
I kept some job.
Fuck.
But I'm saying you're not working here necessarily.
I'm just like going and doing standup.
I'm focusing on standup.
I have my agent and I have management and everything is happening.
I,
last year I did JFL I'm handling it.
I'm handling your some clubs right now because in those places that has like a
huge Brazilian community.
Okay.
I'm doing an English,
but I'm a throw a little Portuguese in there with them.
Yeah.
So that's,
that's new man.
It's,
I did everything that I wanted to do in Brazil.
I did a talk show,
I did movies,
I did in my old series.
I directed a movie director,
the Cedars and I thought it was like I'm 42,
it's time for me to try something new.
That's why I came here and I'm using my son about that.
That's the bad part.
But that's okay.
Yeah,
we were talking about that before.
That is a,
that's a crazy situation is a very emotional,
bringing my kids there.
And,
uh,
last time that I was leaving and he was like,
you find the most important in your life.
Why are you searching for something so far away?
And I thought,
and I told him,
this is important,
this is very important for me,
but it is selfish.
This is something that I wanted to do and for my career was important because I
didn't,
I don't,
I lost a lot in my country.
Well,
with the lawsuits in the last TV shows,
I lost a lot.
I lost money.
I thought was a little dangerous for me to keep doing it over there.
And I got a death threat.
There was that made me a little dinner and I didn't actually went public to talk
about the death threat.
And as the death threat over,
he was,
because one of my last suits,
I cannot be that specific because it was an open.
So if I say exactly who he was,
now be sued again,
right.
Because,
uh,
you know,
yeah,
I'm sort of gate,
I'll be,
uh,
offending someone's order because I,
but I knew what happened and I felt I didn't feel safe there for a little bit.
I'm not saying that a runaway,
but I can't seem smart to come over here and spend some time and build something
and uh,
and maybe be here.
It was,
it was hard for me that I could get hurt because of the nature of my job.
Now when you're over here and you're trying to do standup,
do you,
are you,
do you structure your act out?
Do you have like how do you do it?
Do you write it out on paper or on a computer?
Do you put it up on this thing over here?
Put it on your phone every year and then I keep rehearsing and I go on stage and
a half to two and I say it,
that's what I do.
I memorize everything that I'm going to say.
Not Everything but a,
it gets natural.
It's the way you do it.
Yeah.
Just memorize everything that I'm going to write because if I mess up a word or
two,
I can kill a joke and I want everything to work flawlessly.
So that's why I memorize.
It looks natural,
but I memorize everything.
But it's very hard for me to interact with the audience because every time
there's someone like hack,
call me all jokes,
all jokes comes in Portuguese in my head
and I have to translate.
Right,
right,
right.
At the time and I lose time.
He's very frustrating.
Oh yeah.
And I even say this on stage,
like I was doing a show the other day and this guy,
he just scream,
you suck.
It was like a batch or was a bar show and what I say to order when it,
when I am stressed out,
I just mess up words and now always happened.
And he was like,
you said,
I wanted to say go fuck yourself.
And I said,
gonna fuck myself.
Look at me like fuck yourself.
It's very hard to interact with you.
Also,
most tiny man is difficult to do it in another language.
It's not my natural thing.
So everything's on your phone.
You don't write it on a computer or a notebook.
You write on a computer?
Yeah.
I ran into computer because I can write and it's easier to type.
It's first of all,
it's a bigger right.
You're looking at a big 15 inch screen and I can type without looking at my
fingers and so when I have ideas I can get them out really quick and I don't
have to say them.
I just look at it on the screen and then I'll write many versions of it and then
I go over it and I smoke a little weed and then start editing,
twisting it around.
That's the first word.
What I basically do is I get it to a point where I know that I have something to
talk about.
I know I have a framework and I know where there's some punchlines and then I
write it out on paper so that when I write it down on paper,
I can see it better in my head.
I remember it better.
Then I bring it to the stage,
but I don't have a rigid structure.
I loose with it because I want to be able to feel it in the moment,
whether or not this is good.
Perfect.
You know?
So when I go onstage,
I was like,
say if I'm doing a joke about a coffee,
whatever,
I I'll,
I'll go,
you know,
I drink too much fucking coffee.
I've got a real problem and here's how I know I have a problem.
And then I'll go into it and then I'll start talking about all the different
EHRs and then I'll listen to the recording and I'll go,
that part sucks.
I got to fix this part and this part is stupid and this part is sloppy.
But that part got a laugh.
Okay.
But you know what?
It'd be even funnier if I said it clearer.
Like maybe I need to say it this way,
you know?
And then I'll just,
and then it's this constant process of writing,
writing it out,
going on stage,
live recording,
all sets,
listening to the recording and then writing again.
Do you,
uh,
when you listen to those sets,
do you keep the funny ones or is there sometime they should do like a funny
joke,
but you don't like it?
Does that happen to some type of thing?
Yeah,
yeah.
Yeah.
I don't,
it's,
it's fuel ship.
Cheap.
Yeah.
But he was funny.
You're like,
you've got to laugh,
but it's not good.
Yeah.
That's sure.
Absolutely.
Yeah.
You've got to be careful that you don't,
he don't want to be a hack,
you know?
That's what,
that's what a hack is.
Someone who tells like obvious stupid jokes that only make dumb people laugh or
someone who does.
I'm tired.
Beaten down material.
Like the jokes that you know,
that other people have done already.
You know,
you to know that you just would know based on your,
okay.
Like,
here's a perfect example that Stephen Fry,
do.
You know,
Stephen Fry says,
yes,
this is a famous comedian.
He used this recently.
He said,
uh,
something about,
I would,
I would love to come back to life as a drug sniffing dog.
You know,
could you imagine being a drug sniffing dog at the airport?
Just smelling everything.
Ah,
AH,
getting high.
Like he was saying about how that is such an obvious stupid joke.
It's so many people have done that.
And that's a joke where man I bet probably hundreds of comedians are doing,
don't joke about that.
It's just like an obvious premise.
And you know,
like you were saying earlier that sometimes people would say jokes that you've
said and you,
you're,
you have a hard time explaining.
That's my joke.
And to them it's just an anecdote or then it's just something funny that they
heard.
Sometimes people go on stage and their act consists of really obvious premises
that they have probably already heard someone covered before.
That's a hack.
Yeah.
That's why it's difficult.
Uh,
there's a huge challenge for me because I have been doing for 17 years,
but in another country,
so you guys,
you guys,
there's a huge role that you guys already followed.
So if you hear something about that's old,
maybe for me it's not right.
And I don't want to be that guy in,
in what I realize is that people don't point that out to you.
Well,
you could ask people.
Yeah,
yeah.
If you're friends with comics,
like okay,
you could ask.
Okay.
And they'll tell you.
Yeah.
That's why,
uh,
like a the other day this guy was doing a joke and I kind of thought about,
taglines,
a tagline.
Yeah.
And he got uncomfortable for me,
like telling he all of this,
what about this?
And feels was like,
yeah,
it will,
it's difficult,
man to connect with comedians.
It's not that easy because they all have huge problems.
They all have.
And Man,
I was like in a group of guys,
one was like ex drug addict and the,
the ones was a drunk and they had like huge problems and I was like,
I have friends.
I don't
go,
man.
Yeah.
You got to be like,
Oh,
you've got a jeep and you've got a fucking goal into the bottom to search for
something good.
And I understand this process,
but at the same time,
do I really have to go through all that to come with them?
Something Great.
No,
you don't get ideas.
And this crystal,
Leah actually has a bit about that I don't want to do as bit,
but it's basically a bit about how good his childhood was and how close he is
with his family.
And everybody thinks that you have to have a fucked up childhood to be Canadian.
Eh,
it's not true.
You just have to be funny.
People are funny for different reasons.
Some people are funny because they always enjoy standup.
I mean if you,
if you grow up in joining standup comedy and then become a standup comedian,
there's nothing wrong with that.
You don't have to be a drug addict.
Do you?
And I,
and I'm not going to be because I tried,
uh,
Marie,
yeah.
Once two years ago and I stayed hide for 14 days straight of God's man.
Did you eat it 14 days.
And I dunno if smoke it wasn't a vaporizer.
Is that,
yeah,
vaporize.
Vaporize it.
Yeah.
And I say hi for 14 days and I thought it doesn't right.
It doesn't.
I wasn't high.
Right.
Well I really wasn't the second day,
right like it,
but I thought it was like disconnected from reality.
Well sometimes that does happen and I know a story about a guy who is a straight
laced guy who took some marijuana edibles so that he could get to sleep and he
had a real problem.
Like he got suicidal and freaked out and became just irrationally anxious.
He had crippling anxiety and some time for some time for weeks and he's a
confident guy and a very handsome,
big muscular guy.
Like he just like you would never imagine this guy have any antianxiety.
I think some people have just the chemistry of different individuals.
I wasn't bar for that and that's what the doctor told me because
I went to the psychiatrist.
Wow,
you went to sleep.
I swear to God,
I'm dead week.
That week I went to the psych guy through smell and I told him no,
I smoked that thing like 14 days ago and I still high in.
He looked at me and he gave me some,
some cycle one,
he gave me some pills and I was like,
Oh,
if you stay high until tomorrow,
take these pills.
Because what he told me,
it's something that I didn't know that he can be a trigger if you're has some
tendencies of his schizophrenia and a psychopath,
or if you have,
which was not my case.
And He's told this is very rare,
but it can happen,
which is not your case.
And I,
it was happy because of the up and the next day I was okay and I felt okay and I
did and took the pills and it was crazy,
man.
Fuck crazy.
And I remember that I,
I decided to record it,
but I was like,
okay,
let me,
let me record what I'm thinking.
At least let's get some good experience out of it.
And I remembered that it started to record and I said,
now I'm going to record everything that I'm thinking.
And when I look at the cell phone,
it was 45 minutes,
45 minutes of talking.
And I didn't even realize I just said that I'm going to record now and there was
45 minutes and when I listen to like 15 days after that,
I was like,
I'm so crazy.
Crazy.
I'm gonna die.
I'm never going to understand that.
My son's talking.
Oh,
there's my son talking to me right now.
Wow.
That was one hit of available.
No,
it was more than one a budget hit.
It was a bunch.
Oh,
you're too tall.
You're big.
You're like a 250 pounds.
So fucking use it a lot.
Oh,
so they were saying keep hitting it because you're tall.
Because I wasn't feeling it.
Oh No.
But when I felt it,
I felt for 14
people.
That's one of the big problems with people when they first try,
they tried too much.
That's what happened.
Yeah.
Someone just says take another hit.
It is a happy man.
I tell people,
if you thinking about trying marijuana going there a little bit,
that's it.
I don't feel anything.
Shut the fuck up.
Leave it alone.
It'll.
You'll eventually feel something that's done for,
yeah,
it's leave it alone.
That's crazy,
man.
There's so many people selling weeds and stuff in there.
This is not even cool anymore.
Weed's not cool.
I don't know.
It's like people are suffering.
When I do shows,
there's a lot of people talk about why this book,
this and his mouth that he was like,
man,
it's legal now.
Juice.
It's not dangerous and I think it's good.
He has to be.
There you go.
Yeah.
Well it definitely should be.
It doesn't affect me that way for me.
I've been smoking in a long time.
It's pretty easy.
I just chills me out.
Makes me,
it actually makes me nicer.
It makes me like a more calm person.
Does that makes more,
more sensitive to other people's feelings?
Did you ever smoke because you fell that short intervals or like stressed the
house and no,
I'm going to treat,
I'm not going to perform well in this meeting or something and he just smoking.
No,
it doesn't work like that for me.
Like if I'm stressed
out and I work out,
if I'm stressed out,
that's,
that's my best for alleviating that.
Marijuana is good for me for thinking,
for contemplating and going over things and it's not,
it's not good for me for stress.
Like for street.
What if I feel like tense tension I work out.
That's,
that's what gets it out of me.
I always wanted to ask you one thing.
Uh,
it's completely different subjects.
Can I ask,
uh,
when you're doing interviews at the end,
those fights,
did you ever feel threatened somehow know what looks like wait,
at least once I'm s no,
no,
no.
One thing that I hope the fighters realizes that what I'm trying to do is only
get them to express themselves.
I want them to shine.
I really genuinely want them.
They won this big fight I want,
I want them to express themselves.
I want them to maybe maximize their marketing,
their marketability and just like tell the world how they feel.
Like that's a credibly unusual experience to win a big fight in the cage on
paper view in front of millions of people.
My goal is only to try to get them to communicate the better and to let them
know that I'm there to support them.
That's all I'm ever trying to do.
Or if it,
you know.
Yeah.
Like I was saying before,
before we started talking to,
I have a lot of fight at friends and MMA.
Sweetest guys.
People consider what they do for a living.
It's crazy.
So crazy.
Yeah.
Damn young from that lay.
Ninja Shogun.
They'll,
oh,
how's Ninja doing these days,
man?
Add less time to talk to him.
He got some,
he got some,
uh,
I don't know if it was because of the fighting.
I cannot say that,
but the,
he's speech sheets a little slow.
It is already hard to understand.
Even Shogun,
they have this,
what they called the whole nace,
which is the way of speaking.
They come from at this state,
which is very hard to understand what they say from queer timber.
Right?
Yeah.
Could achieve by people.
We don't poker chips.
Sometimes when we speak to too fast,
you don't understand that much.
But a Nisha,
I think he got some,
some injuries and the scars in his head.
I think he got some surgeries and I think he had surgery on her.
She was fine at the time.
People are kicking people in soccer kicking and he was one of the best.
He was good.
Yeah,
he was an animal.
He was really young too.
And at the end he was like getting knocked out with slaps.
That's the scariest thing is when you see their chin go,
when their ability to take a po.
What's craziest?
Shogun seems to be making a resurgence.
It's crazy.
He amazing.
He w I w I will you still be very good friends with one of his coaches.
And after the fight would Henderson the first one,
which was like a grand,
remembered that fucking chaos.
That was a chaos.
And I was talking to him and he was like,
you don't even imagine how talent that this guy is.
But uh,
he kind of focus,
if he was focused,
he would kick his ass in life fucking tour minutes.
So he just,
that's the way they do it in the shoe box.
They like to fight.
They like to fucking just go at it.
He m and Cyborg and of underlay and understand are sort of the same thing the
way they do.
It's just like,
let's go to war and sometimes the game changed in,
but shoguns like learning,
you can see the,
he's like improving Steven proofing and like,
I think this is like 36,
34.
His last fight,
he looks sensation Aman.
I mean he looked like a fucking killer is crazy.
He can take a shot again now.
It's weird.
It's like,
I mean he got knocked out by a few different guys and he's lost some fights,
some tough fights,
but his last fight he looked as good as he's looking years.
It's,
it's sad for me when I see like,
uh,
I don't know why he's always with Brazina's but when I see like an old,
an old fighter getting his ass beat too quick.
Yup.
I remember his fight with Sonnen.
That was,
that was,
yeah,
well he got caught.
He got caught in a guillotine.
But it's fast.
The guy pre framed for like six months.
And that's very frustrating.
Remember when rice,
he went back to five with Hugues down was like,
yeah,
well Matt Hughes was in his prime then,
you know,
and he was so strong and the boys just wasn't,
he wasn't physically capable to do it.
Right.
He didn't look the same,
you know,
it just didn't look like he was physically capable the same way in.
And you know Matt,
he was his fucking talent.
Unbelievably talented.
And when he,
when he got on top of hoisting,
it was smashing him.
I was like,
oh yeah,
that's hard to watch.
How to watch.
Yeah,
but that's the life.
I mean that is the life they chose.
You know,
a chocolate.
Dell just got knocked out by Tito Ortiz and that was hard to watch because you
could tell he just can't take a punch.
And I wasn't that five that went in there to wash it.
It was,
it was bad.
it wasn't,
it wasn't moving right either.
The thing about when fighters take a lot of knockout losses,
one of the things it's very becomes a parent is there balance looks off and
their movement doesn't look the same.
Like their neurology,
their,
they don't,
their body doesn't move as you can look the same but it doesn't react the same
way.
I mean even Anderson when he lost his style bender,
I think style bender would have been a tough fight for him at any point in his
career.
Cause style bender is just fantastic,
super technical.
But Anderson looked like he was a step behind the Anderson of old,
like the Anderson that knocked out Vituro the Anderson that,
you know,
you go back to the early days,
Anderson that knocked out Chael Sonnen and Anderson was a fucking,
he was just an assassin.
He was so good.
He just knew what to do and when to do it.
And when the style bender fight,
he just looked like he was a little off little office.
But he's also 46 I see.
No,
he's,
I think he's won one year older than me.
He's 43 he's only 42 yeah,
we did.
We did,
we did a show together.
Uh,
we do a show this show on Netflix called the ultimate beastmaster,
which a Brazilian
Netflix we know is a,
is here as well.
Terry crews did an American,
we do,
we do like all hosts from different countries and we meet and it's like American
Ninja Warrior for Netflix.
Oh,
okay.
And they have like host from different countries and we have the Brazilians and
the Italians and the French guys.
And,
and I did his show with Andrew.
So he's a sweet guy.
He's a great guy,
great guy.
He's a great,
yeah,
I mean he's one of the all time greats.
I mean,
I had the honor of calling a lot of his fights
in his crazy because,
yeah.
And it's crazy.
Uh,
when you're talking about the God,
the guy's getting older.
I remember I taught,
I taught with Minataro.
Uh,
he was like three or four and it was like two,
two,
two fights after he actually retired.
And I asked him,
why,
why you keep doing it,
you don't have to,
you don't,
you don't have to prove anything to another one.
And what he said to me,
I think was so fair.
He was like,
I fought when this thing wasn't giving me any money.
Right?
So just give,
let me lose the fight or two and get some money at the end of my career because
I deserve that.
He wasn't like,
of course he was going there to win,
but it's like I want to take the risk because I was fighting in Japan getting on
an old $5,000 and now that the game,
it's like bringing you so much money,
I'm going to retire.
Let me just do
well.
Minataro not,
not only was he a pioneer and one of the great MMA heavyweights of all time,
but he's so important for MMA because he showed that heavyweights can fight off
their back and then heavyweights can win by triangle.
Like when he triangled Mark Coleman and was tapping guys with arm bars when he
beat Bob Saget,
Bob Sapp on his fucking crazy that that is one of the greatest MMA fights in the
history of the sport.
375 pound Bob Sapp Minataro only probably way two 30.
And he wound up tapping with an arm bar.
It was fucking crazy.
And after get spiked on his head,
which still apparently fucks with him to his day,
his neck was fucked up permanent because of that.
Yes.
I didn't know that.
375 pound guy who doesn't even look like a human,
he looked like a,
like a comic book,
either smashes him on his head and metatarsal recovered.
And I mean he was one of the toughest guys of all time,
but she was run by a truck when he wasn't in jail.
That's that scarring.
So it's run by crazy.
Yeah,
that's crazy.
I mean he's um,
he's one of the most important figures in the history of the sport.
And then I think Fabrisio took it to another level cause for breezy over doom
probably has the best guard in the history of the sport is the history of the
heavyweight division.
I mean,
when he caught fade or when he had him in his triangle and he had them locked up
like that,
you don't get away with that guy like you,
you might get out of some people's guard,
not Fabrizio.
That motherfucker locks people up.
And I got to thinking,
man,
I'm here just because of
my respect for him.
You know,
when he reached out to me it was like,
okay,
I'll get your friend on 100% thank you thing and now he is a great guy and
that's what I will,
that's why I asked you if,
uh,
if you kind of feel threatened because when people get there in the fight,
you don't know what it was going to happen.
And when your goal over there to talk with one,
you can say a wrong thing at the wrong man.
I don't know.
Or maybe you can make mistakes.
Sure.
So my,
my intention is always to just to make them look good.
That's all I'm trying to do.
I'm trying to do is just get them to express themselves and,
and,
and also put some emotion to how great their performance was.
Perfect.
Yeah,
but it's a weird job,
you know,
to also be a comedian,
it's a strange combination of do they go watch you sometimes.
Sometimes.
Yeah.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
Who is good.
That's very good.
And uh,
for me now it's like,
uh,
I'm here to try this comment a theme.
And so you're getting up in Los Angeles and a traveling anywhere,
right?
Yeah.
I have a Gig on Rhode Island.
Rhode Island.
What,
Portuguese people?
Yeah,
I have a Gig Dad.
Uh,
I did the Gotham comedy club lasts less than two weeks ago.
I had climbed the clubs,
so it's hard to get a lot of Brazilians and come to see you.
They want you to speak Portuguese.
They do in,
some of them don't speak English.
Really?
There's like always like two or three at the thought that was in Portuguese.
But that was so good to see you.
But
everything is sad.
Right.
So that happened.
But it's,
it's hard maybe because I have to build an audience here and it's gonna take
some time.
Do you do a podcast?
I don't.
You should write should.
Yeah,
definitely.
Definitely.
It's a good,
I think every comedian,
like every comedian has an Instagram page.
Every comedian officers should have a podcast.
It's very simple to do.
It's not something that we do that much in Brazil.
So Ah,
maybe it could be the pioneer of that to recast.
Yeah.
I mean you're the pioneer for standup.
Youtube is something huge in Brazil.
Well that's a great way to start because with all you need is a Webcam and you
can start your podcast just on youtube.
Do My,
I have my,
my,
my channel Youtube got like 2 million subscribers.
Like on Twitter I have 12 million people following.
It's a lot,
man.
That's a lot 12 meeting people following me,
my Brazilian Instagram,
I got like 1.5 million people.
People,
people are very active in social media in Brazil.
It is good.
It's something that is from our nature to connect with people in Brazil.
So that's why social media huge.
Any was a,
it was like an alternative for the traditional media.
What is this the most influential person on Twitter?
Look at you motherfucker.
I got a story on the New York Times.
That's crazy.
New York Times magazine saying you're the most influential person on Twitter.
That's incredible.
Now what?
Why?
Why are they saying you're the most influential would,
what were you doing that was influencing people?
I have no idea.
I was surprised.
Monday I woke up and it was story on the New York Times saying that I was the
most inflammation profile,
Twitter and in second place the Dalai Lama take this one Dalai Lama or my third.
I was the first one.
So these,
they did like a huge story about me.
Wow.
And a credible,
it was man.
Peter was something huge in Brazil.
What is the difference between the way people use Twitter in Brazil and America?
Is there a difference?
No.
For for me,
I just use Twitter for jokes.
That's what I did for quite some time.
It was a Twitter lost a lot of his strength in Brazil because people like to
connect members or salts.
Facebook is huge and Instagram is huge.
So you have your family over there,
you have uh,
you have have everything.
Hey,
you have your people but you feel talking to you for just like scrape Twitter
feels like you're screaming in.
Someone is going to listen.
It's not like on Facebook that people follows you and then if he likes you,
your post is going to be like in the,
in the top of his page.
Twitter,
there's just something that is there.
So it lost a lot of power in Brazil.
But one thing that is happening right now is our new president and we have a new
president now that is a right wing guy who was just a lacked and then he got
stabbed.
He was like,
when did he get stabbed?
There was like two months ago during the process of the election,
holy shit got stabbed in the gut.
Like oh yeah,
you do see that.
And that was crazy.
I didn't hear about that.
And he is like a very white rain.
He warned the election and he is trying to do with Twitter with Trump did where
he's doing and here like run instead of going to press conferences and
everything who just go on Twitter and see what he wants.
Wow.
Yeah.
Twitter is a unique in the way people just use it to insult people and still
angry.
It's so angry.
Like if you just,
only if you didn't know anything about people and you just looked on Twitter and
just like saw how you like when people must be fighting in the streets,
it must be just a bloodbath out there.
If you really thought that people interacted in the real world the way they do
on Twitter,
you would think that everywhere is just weapons and clubs and picking shouldn't
running people over with cars wishing everyone dies.
But I think man,
there's a difference and I think we have to acknowledge that there's a
difference between your behavior on the web and outside of them
for sure.
And sometimes you don't realize that,
oh the ward is bothering,
everybody is sensitive and everything else if you go outside is not that much.
It's the same.
The same.
It was always,
it's
a distorted lens that you could see humans through.
It's not how people really are and it's also,
it's not a healthy way to communicate because you don't worry about what the
person thinks about what you're saying.
You're things that you don't necessarily even really mean because you're trying
to be inflammatory,
you know?
[inaudible] I mean that's a lot of it.
A lot of is just screaming,
screaming for attention and insulting people and,
and then you look at people's pages.
That's the most disturbing thing to me.
When someone say something Shitty to me,
I'll go to their page and I see they're just saying shitty things all day long.
Like kind of life is this man,
so fucking terrible life.
What I'm doing right now,
I have this series that I'd want Instagram where I just,
I get like the Guy Kersey me or saying some shit about me and I just show his
face and it's enough.
And it's funny because it's,
it's funny to see who is actually,
who hates me.
Then a,
I called this,
the people who hates me and then I put work in road and then all his like his
face because stunned than they are.
It's enough for you to see,
oh that's fucking,
you don't have to take things too serious because if you take a look of their
lives it's,
you can see why they are so mad.
Yeah.
There's,
there's a lot of that is a lot of angry and they'll,
most of them have private accounts.
Like you can't look at their pictures.
They're hiding,
they're hiding who they are.
They just talk shit in the comments.
That should an bro.
Yeah.
That's weak shit.
[inaudible] that shit.
So giving people a chance to like just real blind shots,
this crazy.
I think that that the being anonymous on the web,
it's a good,
it's a good thing because it allows you to be free at the same time.
Whistle blowers for people like proporting crimes,
reporting,
corruption of course report,
you know,
like that.
For that it's critical.
That is,
there is a,
uh,
there is a way to do it and they'll expose yourself.
But at the same time he creates that.
But it's,
you know,
it's the sign up for the new era,
Bro.
Just a new thing that we all have to navigate.
Is it just a new thing?
And it's like we were talking about earlier with social media being so recent in
human history,
there's never been anything where you could just talk to the whole world and do
it from your phone while you're sitting at a red light.
You could say something.
There's a story about this woman.
What was her name?
Justine Sacco was at the woman's name who said something racist.
I went to a plane.
Yes,
yes.
She said,
I'm going to Africa.
Hope I don't get aids.
Just kidding.
I'm white.
Lol.
So she was fucked up on Ambien and she was a,
or a Xanax or ambien.
I forget what it was.
She was,
she was on some sort of psych medication and uh,
something that affects your brain and drank too.
She had a couple of drinks,
just thought she was being funny and then wakes up 16 hours later in Africa and
her life is over.
That's crazy.
Fucking crazy.
And it was just one of those days where there was like a slow news cycle and
people just jumped on that tweet.
And the thing about it too is that they don't want you to recover from something
like that.
They want that's,
that's you for the rest of your life.
That's what I felt.
I'm the baby fucker.
Yeah.
That's,
yeah.
So everything that say right now is like,
what is it?
You like fucking babies and never fucked a baby.
I don't think they are attractive.
I don't feel attracted at all.
Do you foresee a time ever where you will go back to Brazil?
No,
I do.
I do go back to what I mean go back to do standup and I uh,
I don't see damn man the challenges here when the freedom that I think I have
here and maybe I don't,
maybe I will face this,
this,
this whole thing,
the same thing when I get famous or when I went,
when I get,
no,
you won't.
It's way easier here.
You from what?
From what you're explaining to me,
but look at Lou Louis or is a different case because it's not what he said on
stage and you know,
I mean it's,
he got you caught up in the wave of the me too movement too.
Whereas if this same exact instance happened in the past,
it's not the same thing.
Yeah,
it was a bit of comparison.
But I got like Daniel Tosh did the rape joke and that was over in like,
like that.
And do you know what,
what happened there with a joke?
No,
he was looking,
provides them with the audience or something.
He was improvising with the audience.
Here's the deal.
Um,
he was at the laugh factory.
He wasn't supposed to be there.
Don,
my rera who is his friend,
said,
hey,
why don't you go up and do some standup because I don't have any materials.
Just go up and fuck around.
Just sit.
They'll be happy to see you.
He goes,
okay.
So he goes on stage.
He goes,
I don't have any material.
So,
uh,
what do you guys want to talk about?
And some guy yells out rape and he goes,
what?
What?
What's funny about it?
Like he's like making fun of the guy.
Like what are you talking about?
What's funny about rape?
He's like,
there's nothing.
He goes like,
well,
what's funny about rip?
The humiliation,
the violence?
And some woman yells out,
actually there's nothing funny about rape.
So he goes,
when are you finding five guys or,
so he's just feeling Daniel Tosh.
So it probably would have been just one of those moments in a live crowd filled
with drunk people.
But she wrote a blog about where she was the victim.
She wrote this huge blog about him calling for her to get raped,
which is not exactly what he did.
It's in the context of being heckled.
You understand what it is and he kind of had to have some sort of an apology for
it,
but then all these other people jumped in and then it became a moment where
people could show that they don't support rape or they don't support what we
call rape culture.
The usual has a platform.
Yes,
yes.
That's what happened.
And that's what happened with me as well.
People don't want to analyze context anymore.
Exactly.
And we are very,
uh,
we are available.
We will the,
we as Comedians,
we are talking,
we are ourselves.
We are not playing a character.
So if you take,
if I take your jokes,
Joe,
out of context from your special Netflix,
I can get some,
some clicks if a boy,
yeah,
I'm sure if I wanted,
but I think people are getting tired of it and now they understand the process.
But what I felt was the beginning of that,
especially in your country where you don't have a long history of stand up.
Yeah.
So that's why I lost
money and uh,
that's why I lost a lot of money.
You're the motherfucking Lenny Bruce or Brazil.
Yeah,
man.
You know,
someone will give me the deck granted in a future,
but now,
now you want to be now off Ian America.
No,
no,
no.
Not only that,
but that's way,
uh,
what,
what people said to me in what I felt was that I was,
a lot of people said I was using this freedom of speech argument to offend
people.
Right?
We,
you hear that in America too and we've just not the case.
But then he's mad at off freedom of speech because we had a law in,
uh,
in Brazil a long time ago where people are like trying to uh,
regulate,
uh,
comments on the web.
Oh,
if I feel offended I can ask someone to delete that.
Sold the golf with the government was trying to regulate that and a,
and the law was approved.
So like after you wasn't approved but that the law was like changing after the
voting.
But when he becomes at the end,
the government was like,
when he was getting the time with the voting,
the governor was like,
okay,
what about he fight?
Take some tweets as well.
That offend me.
So the government tried to get into the weight of things.
So it is a matter of freedom of speech.
When this is going to end,
it becomes with a joke,
but maybe can end with the government shutting you up.
Yes.
I have a friend in Venezuela,
a comedian friend.
His name is Nacho.
He was,
he was kicked out of the country because of some jokes he did.
Whoa.
He's Ken.
Go back his living in Miami right now because he,
if he goes back to Venezuela right now,
the government is going to pull Camille own jail.
Maybe kill him.
I don't know.
Wow.
What was his jokes about?
Yeah.
I don't know what his joke was about,
but he was making fun of the government.
But then like one year after that he makes some jokes about people with down
syndrome and then the golfer and felt that he,
he uh,
when he has to go to jail because of the Dow Syndrome,
Joe,
they were using that thing to take him out of the streets.
So it's Dasia result there,
man.
It's not that easy to do comedy outside of America.
You built that freedom.
Yeah.
You hear about it all the time.
People in other countries that say jokes and they get in trouble.
Uh,
like there was something in Thailand,
there was some,
someone made a joke about the king and they locked him in jail and it's,
it's very danger.
Does a lot of countries where it's very dangerous,
very dangerous to speak out against the government.
Yeah.
We're,
we're really,
really fortunate here.
So like for you,
when you see Americans complaining about freedom of speech over here and not,
not being able to say whatever you want,
it's kind of a joke,
right?
Yes.
That's exactly what I feel.
It's just like,
if you want to be an asshole,
just deal with the consequences.
Yes.
That's what I feel.
I'm going to hustle.
But when someone stopped you on the street,
so you're a piece of shit,
I was like,
yeah,
right.
But that's okay.
That's end there.
I am a piece of shit and that's where it has to and you know,
don't take it personal.
That's what I,
I feel that is,
is difficult to do a comedy out there in here.
You have this freedom of doing it then I think is,
is beautiful.
It's beautiful.
It's something that you guys built.
Do you think that it's going to change in Brazil and then maybe the standup
comedy could actually see,
because one of the things that happened in America is that Lenny Bruce,
because he didn't just tell jokes,
he actually talked about social issues on stage.
It actually expanded people's ideas of what these social issues are and how
critical they are.
It changed culture and a lot of ways and jokes.
One of the things about standup comedy that does help to change culture is safe.
You have an opinion and I have an opinion.
If your opinion is different than mine,
um,
you say something,
I'm like,
well I don't agree with that.
I think this,
but if you say something and you make me laugh,
even if I don't agree with it,
it sneaks in my head like you have a point.
If your point is so good that it makes me laugh,
even if I don't agree with it,
like God damn it,
he got it.
He got in there.
So you get,
you can propagate ideas inside someone's consciousness.
You can,
you could sneak them in.
We have a few people doing it in Brazil.
Some,
uh,
in the,
I used to have this TV show called CQC and we used to do comedy in Congress.
We used to go in interview congressmen and make fun of them.
And,
uh,
we got kicked out of the congress anyway again.
Then people brought,
brought us back to the congress.
But he all,
you all reached a point when it's about money and if the end,
if someone is not willing to put money in your product,
you don't do it in money is connected to politics and politics and brands and
the TV stations.
For you to have a TV station in Brazil,
you need a authorization by the government.
So you're not death completely free to do what you want to do it.
But uh,
but you have some people doing it and comedy's getting is getting big.
Standup is getting huge in Brazil.
You use connected to youtube.
I have a lot of big comedians doing like huge theaters.
I used to do like 5,000 seats theaters in Brazil.
So it's,
it's becoming,
it's becoming an option.
Wow.
5,000 seat theaters.
Yeah.
Wow,
man,
you'll do it here.
It's 5,000 to do it all the time.
It's just like,
wow,
she's doing like 10,000 too.
But what I'm saying is it's crazy that you started out doing like a
sadomasochist club.
Yes.
And then you go to a 5,000 seat theater.
That's pretty amazing.
That's what I built with some friends and I feel that I'm proud of that,
to open this,
this,
uh,
this discussion and this chance because I have a lot of people doing it right
now,
getting money out of it.
My comedy club,
we bay,
well
Comedians,
every time they go off stage,
this little lake here,
they got like 10 books.
Yeah.
But it's okay.
We consider that as a business,
uh,
over that and that's that serious and this is awesome.
That's fantastic.
It's so cool that you started that.
I mean,
that's gotta be really a good feeling to know that all these people that are
doing it now that are professional comedians like you,
you took the first steps.
Yeah.
I feel proud,
man.
That was a lot of people that try that.
I probably have all of them watching this right now.
I don't know anyone who has ever done it in one language and then made it over
in America afterwards.
I'm trying to think.
I can't think of any,
I don't think anybody in English.
Uh,
oh yeah,
I don't,
I can't think of anybody that started out in another country and then made it an
American.
What is the name of the Russian guy?
They always do the [inaudible] still doing the comedy store.
They used to say Yaakov.
SMIRNOFF.
Yeah.
Great Guy.
He,
I think he's Russian.
Yes,
he's rushing,
but I think he's been over here most of his life.
Uh,
I don't think he started in Russia.
I think his whole idea in Russia,
they say,
yeah,
this whole thing.
Yeah.
So he was doing like a character?
No,
no,
no.
He speaks,
I mean,
he definitely speaks Russian.
Okay.
And he definitely is from Russia,
but uh,
he definitely plays it up too.
And He,
you know,
he's been over here forever.
He has his own theater in what does that place where those old folks live?
Branson,
Missouri.
Yeah.
It's like one of those weird,
like super religious places.
Yeah.
It's a strange area.
It's a star.
Very strange.
Like,
like you talk to people about it and Branson,
Missouri and people go,
you're like,
it's,
it's not a place where like Dave Chappelle goes to play.
Do you go through those places?
No,
I do not.
There's only so many places I go,
I don't have any time to,
I don't want to,
you know,
I'm not trying to run uphill.
No.
If you don't get it.
Ah,
that's all right.
I'll go to Chicago.
Okay.
You know,
I'll go somewhere where people can get to it.
Yeah.
This just,
I don't have time or not.
What I'd concentrate on now.
I mean,
the ground's already been broken.
Right.
I'm not breaking any new ground.
All I'm trying to do is write good stuff.
Right.
Good material,
do good work,
and I'm just trying to make people happy.
I'm trying to make them laugh.
That's all I'm trying to do.
I just try to,
when they go and they get a babysitter and they come to a comedy club,
I want to do my best.
That's all I want to do.
So that's all I think about.
Do you still have a gavel?
A lot of like movie offers and I get offers for stuff,
but I don't act.
I don't do it anymore.
I tried it a little bit.
It's just not my thing.
It just takes time.
It's not necessary.
And all my friends that do it,
you know,
like my friend Brian just call me from a movie set the other day.
He goes,
he goes,
you're so right.
Fuck this.
He goes,
I'm sitting in my trailer for 16 hours.
He's like,
I fucking hate this shit.
I don't want to do this.
I just got another offer for another movie that's not that good.
And I don't want to do that either.
You know,
you could,
you could do a movie and put so much effort and time and do it and no one will
see it.
Like maybe it'll be opposite some fucking big Avengers movie and nobody goes to
see your movie.
And it's out of the movie theater and you're like,
shit,
I spent so much time doing that.
No one cares.
The thing about movies too,
that's interesting is there so many of them.
It's not like you're ever going to see all the movies.
There's so many movies and every week there's new movies.
If you really stop and think about how fucking insane that is,
there must be thousands and thousands and thousands of movies.
You can't possibly see the mall.
Like if you just want to be entertained,
like you could see movies to the end of time.
You could just sit in front of your fucking Netflix and just to your eyes fall
out of your head watching movies.
It's crazy.
It's almost no need to make more movies were good,
painless,
crazy.
Yeah,
and it's crazy because movies are getting bigger and bigger and bigger and
bigger because they have to bring you something that takes you out of your
house.
People don't go to the movie to watch Adam Sandler anymore.
Then you want a fucking superhero kicking your face in communion or neck.
That's what they want.
They won't fucking huge stuff.
Yeah,
there's that.
But then people do need comedies like Kevin Hart movies.
They still sell really well.
Like people still want to see something funny,
you know,
that's,
people still need,
it's one of the things about standup and one of the things about funny movies
too is that people need a break from the grind of life.
Life is a horrible grind,
you know,
it's fucking hard man.
It's hard to pay your bills and get up every morning to a job you don't want to
get up to and maybe not even into being married anymore.
And you've got to fucking trudge through that.
Cause maybe you have a children and you decided that it's better to stay for
your children and you're fucking living in hell and your neighbors are current
and the dog won't stop barking and,
and then you just need something.
Just something to give me something.
Give me something funny,
my friend.
That's why I'm so optimistic in life is like what,
what a chance I have of pursuing my dream.
Yeah.
And doing comedy and making people laugh and having fun.
And I'll have to sit in a fucking fucking share for eight hours a day and a new
way,
a job that I like.
Because if you like to be an accountant,
that's okay.
Yeah.
Be happy being an accountant.
Sure.
But uh,
he w he was never for me.
Yeah.
It was never for me.
No,
it was never for me either or any comedian that I know,
everyone that I know was like doing something and living in hell until they
decided to be a comedian or the thought of doing something else.
But you know,
that's,
that's the path of life,
right.
The path of life is,
for some people what we do would be hell.
You know,
for some people that are introverts or that they don't like attention or they
don't like public speaking and they don't,
they're not necessarily funny.
What we do as hell.
If you're wearing a funny person,
you don't know how to make people laugh and you have to go on stage and make
people laugh every night.
That's your job and you have to try hard or there's some sort of pain involved.
Fuck,
that'd be hell.
Did you see?
That was,
that was me.
The last few shows that I did in Brazil,
I felt I felt heavy,
heavy.
If everyone's watching you,
I fell.
I fell that the energy,
I still have very lawyer artists and I'm fine law.
They love me and I love them.
We still have that connection,
but I felt exposed,
not exposed and that's when you,
this is after the baby fuck Joe.
Yeah.
If after me becoming a baby fucker,
but at the time,
that was funny.
Right when you said it.
Everybody laughed.
They laugh a lot.
Yeah.
That was not the case.
My funny to take this joke out of context and put it in the newspaper,
even me,
when I read that,
I was like,
this guy is fucking smashed up.
The rape joke that I did when I ran on a newspaper,
that was the rape joke.
Oh Man,
do you really want me to go that?
We referenced it 20 times.
He was bad.
He was something like a,
I was watching on TV and I don't,
I'm not proud of that.
Okay.
But I was watching on TV,
this woman then she was saying that she was raped and uh,
it was bad.
It was a very bad experience.
You,
she was crying but the camera was,
wasn't showing her face.
It was just showing her mouth.
And she has a huge mustache,
like a huge mustache,
like a fucking lot of hair.
And I made this joke a ball.
Well this guy,
he wasn't,
uh,
this was,
this was kind of a gift because she didn't,
she wouldn't have another opportunity or something.
It was,
it wasn't good.
But I did once,
I was just testing the joke I was doing at one o'clock at night in my comedy
club.
It was like 20 people in the audience.
So you're just fucking around.
I was just fucking around there.
Well,
it was what I saw on TV.
So they were waiting for you to do something like that.
And it was like this journalist was,
was there and he was doing a story for the rolling stone and I was doing,
it was a story about me and then the cover,
and it wasn't in the cover,
but the,
the,
the picture on the cornerstone was me dressed as Jesus,
like bleeding with a crown in all my head.
And that was the,
in the,
in the text was this rape joke.
It was draped joke.
I didn't even ride.
The thing was just like talking with Yardi,
but when that's,
that was taken out of context,
he was hard for me to explain to them,
okay,
this is was me fucking around with like 20 people.
The people couldn't see the difference between me doing any,
wasn't a good yoga at all.
It's not as something that I'm proud of,
but when you're on a stage on your test and some thanks,
just shit comes up.
And I was testing boundaries as well.
I think it was my duty to test some stuff.
Uh,
there's things that you say where you're not thinking them out because your ad
living in the moment and they come out and even you disagree with them as you're
saying.
But this is part of the process of creating material,
especially if there's 20 people in the crowd.
It's late at night.
Like what you do things just to see,
you go down doors,
you open doors,
you don't know what's in there and sometimes you'll say something and then
you'll have the fucking perfect line and it comes out of nowhere.
And the only way you find out is if you take a chance doing it.
Yeah.
That's why I think it's
so fair.
And I was having a discussion with two great big comedians about the Louis sad
that he did recently.
And I think you already talked about this,
but uh,
the guy was testing stuff.
Yeah.
So how can you judge if the work is not done?
It's not even close to done.
He probably,
maybe it did that bit once before if that,
you know.
And the judgment was like,
oh he has to address what happened when him,
I'm pretty sure he'll wheel but not on that sat.
Maybe he didn't address on that set that not his special.
When he has her special,
that's when he framed the thing,
okay that's my work.
But if he's just testing stuff,
you cannot judge by that.
The problem is now everybody wants to judge everything he does and they want to
find him and watch him.
And so now he has to institute this a cell phone policy and all the comedy clubs
he works out.
We have to take your phone and put it in a bag so that no one can get ahold of
it.
It's just a,
it's a real problem.
He's got a real problem.
And it's also a real problem for creating comedy because if people don't
understand that this is what comedy is about,
that comedy is about improvisation and then boiling it down to what's good and
then figuring out what's the best way to express an idea.
Cause sometimes you have an idea and you'd know there's something there,
but you don't know how to say it.
So you just check,
take a chance on one way and then you go,
oh,
that's the offensive.
That's disgusting.
But there's gotta be a way to do it.
Let me find a better way to do.
Of course.
Yeah,
there's many bits that I did.
Um,
like,
uh,
not my last special but the special before where when I first started them,
they were not doing well at all.
They were not doing well at all.
I had to figure out a way to make them funny.
Why didn't you CCED on them?
Because I knew there was something there.
I knew it was something there.
Like for instance,
I have this one bit on women,
uh,
and inventions and that women don't invent a lot of things.
And I took all long time for me to figure out how to do that.
And the best way to do that was to talk about all the great things about women
first.
So I just had to,
I had a talk about,
you know,
like the concept that women are supposed to work,
that we should,
that women are supposed to work as well as raise children,
which is fucking crazy because raising children,
and I'm not saying that every woman should raise children and that they
shouldn't have a career.
But if you,
if you think that it's easy to raise children,
you're out of your fucking mind.
It's one of the most difficult things in the world to just to have the patients
you're dealing with this little people,
you have to teach them things,
you have to re,
you have to give them love and constant attention and it's very,
very time consuming.
It's difficult or,
and these women are making people in their fucking bodies.
It's the most incredible thing that anyone's ever created.
Humans,
you make,
you make humans in your body.
I mean,
that's insane.
And I would go through this whole thing and then I'd say,
so ladies,
I love you.
I think you're amazing,
but let's be honest,
you don't invent a lot of shit.
And then I got into this whole thing about women inventions and then I just
talked about all the great inventions women make.
Okay.
You sat at a different
figure out how to do it.
It took a while to figure out how to do it where the women thought it was funny
where I gave them enough honest,
legitimate credit and said funny things about them that are positive first so
then they feel free to laugh.
Yes,
cause I'm not a dick.
I just have a point that women don't have a lot of shit
outside of say I don't invent anything that I had to get really clear about that
and let's be clear,
we're not talking about us.
I go,
look,
I'm a fucking moron.
I'm never invented shit.
And I'm guessing you're probably pretty dumb too,
which is why you are here listening to me talk.
I was like,
we're not talking about us.
We're talking about inventors and so I was trying to remove people from the
tribal male versus female dynamic.
Just to talk about the fact that in history there have not been like relatively
a lot of women inventors.
Got It.
And so then they fell and then they laughed.
Then it was funny.
It was like,
it worked out great.
It was like closing bit is the same thing with this.
Uh,
the joke that translated from Portuguese to English and uh,
I didn't have any problem doing this in Portuguese because we don't have that
much talking about race and stuff.
He was not that one the n word,
but he was a joke that I used to do that.
I was like,
I saw this guy with a tee shirt,
a written a hundred percent black.
I was going to sprout off his face or run because I find that to the palm of his
hand and said 99% he smiled.
That's said 98% that was the joke that I was doing.
And I had this joke here,
but I just don't late it.
It's like this little,
right?
Yeah,
yeah.
Do.
So this is a case of jug that I trust that it works.
Yeah,
because it's,
well,
rethink has a good punchline.
It's everything,
but people feel very uncomfortable who?
Not The black people.
The people that sit around.
The black guy.
That was,
that was,
I thought it was funny because it wasn't the human,
he was like laughing.
I think it's funny because all of those people,
they didn't feel that they were entitled to laugh around you.
Just kind of fun.
He was a uncomfortable,
but when I sat up as you know what,
you talk about race too much and we don't have that in Brazil,
so sometimes there's some misunderstandings.
So when I put myself in that position then I'm just just a mistake
and I don't speak English.
That's easy.
That's what I get to.
Yeah.
That's what I eat when I,
when I,
when I'm free to do the same thing that your did you set up in a different way?
Well that's,
that's a really interesting angle too that really only someone from another
country can pursue this angle that like you have,
the America is a different culture than you're used to,
so that's probably so many differences.
Oh yeah.
He does a lot of differences.
Freaking Kardashians.
I don't know how you guys squash that shit.
It's just like he's like for cheeks fucking hanging around.
Then we are like,
I [inaudible]
has nothing to it.
The celebrity thing here fucking that's,
that's amazing.
Do you have Instagram celebrities and youtube celebrities in Brazil?
Same kind of thing.
Yeah.
You,
yeah,
we do have a lot of them and people playing video games and kids.
My kid watch plead people playing video games.
Yes.
The same thing.
It's huge over here.
Yeah.
I know people make millions of dollars playing video games.
Crazy like parents tell their kids don't be a loser.
Play video games like wait a minute,
what are you talking about?
These kids are making millions of dollars and what is a loser?
You work all fucking year for 50 grand and this guy is making $500,000 a week
planned youtube playing fucking videos.
Twitter.
It's fucking crazy and youtube gives give you much more money than he does in
Brazil.
But we have the same speech of like I have my,
this youtube channel called Isla Jabara was in Brazil and we are having a lot of
problems with,
we are to getting not monetizing our videos is the same thing.
Oh yeah.
We are suffering to the same problems that they don't know exactly what to do
because advertisers are very wary about certain content and so they have these
deals with these advertisers and so they're trying to suppress content because
they don't want to minimize,
they don't want to lose revenue.
So what they're trying to do is make advertisers happy,
but then the content creators feel like they're being censored.
I mean they are being censored,
but they have to understand what's happening here like this,
this,
all this stuff costs money.
Do you get some of your readers all the time?
All the time.
Fuck man,
that's,
yeah,
they get demonetized.
They get demonetized.
If we talk about specific subjects,
all subjects as well.
Yup.
Well,
not even showing images,
just talking about the subjects,
just subjects.
And we've talked about them and we've,
we've complained about it a little,
but basically,
I mean,
Jamie,
we kind of take this attitude was nothing we could do.
We just kind of keep on trucking.
You could just keep doing it.
Yeah.
Because you're building much more than just,
yeah.
That money is not your main,
it's something,
it's money.
It,
you know,
it could be thousands of dollars for each one that they don't monetize.
But that's not how I,
I don't think about it that way.
I think about it like,
well,
what's important,
what's important is to just say what's on your mind and uh,
whatever.
I mean,
I'm not going to change just so that I get more youtube ad money dead.
That would ruin whatever I'm doing.
So I think they're going to work it out in a better way eventually.
But there's also a thing called a youtube red.
And with youtube red,
even if things get demonetized,
the people that are paying for youtube see you pay for you to read.
So you never get any advertisers and the,
you still like if you got a certain amount of people that are,
I think 50% of our revenue comes from youtube,
red
to various video to video time watched,
kind of cumulative.
So there's,
there's a lot of people are saying,
look,
I'd rather pay x amount of dollars per month and don't,
don't put any ads.
And so I think we're moving towards that,
that sort of,
that model.
But I understand the process as well.
That is brands and they're paying the bills.
You know,
that Google is not a ton free,
isn't the free,
it's all,
all of it.
It's expensive and they're trying to make money too.
So like the only reason for them to allow someone like you or I to put a video
up as they want to be able to profit from it,
send me to,
they're not providing a service just because they're,
they're good people.
They're trying to make money.
So yeah.
But the thing which is a just easier for us is that our revenue comes from shows
and we can do a lot of different stuff,
but they're stupid.
They actually get their money from you too.
Yes.
That's the one that are getting hurt.
Well in the United States the real issue is a conservative speakers cause all
these tech companies,
whether it's youtube or Facebook or what have you,
they all lean left.
They're all very left wing.
So right wing people feel like they get censored off of all these platforms
before other ones maybe less on Facebook.
Right.
Because Facebook,
they,
they actually make money off of people paying attention to shit.
So the more people argue about stuff,
probably the more more eyes they get the money.
Did they get the most of their money is people paying you,
paying you Facebook to promote their content?
Like yeah.
And Facebook doesn't,
you don't make money off of Facebook.
Right.
Is there anybody making money off of Facebook blog posts or yeah,
these people want that is monetizing videos,
videos.
It's very recent,
but not like writing.
Like say if you wrote an essay and they wouldn't pay for that specifically,
but that's where like there's a lot of,
a lot of people like to comment on things and argue about things and so if you
have something controversial on Facebook that's probably value in that because
you're going to get more eyeballs.
Right.
There's a lot of value in controversy.
It's just like what kind of controversy?
So for Youtube,
the big thing is they like if you have like uh,
well specifically Twitter,
Twitter's been,
they've had big issues with it.
Instagram,
not so much with conservative people.
Right.
You don't hear that as much?
I don't think so.
No.
It's more of a Twitter,
youtube thing and it's conservatives feel like they're being pushed out because
almost overwhelmingly all the tech companies are liberal.
They're all very left wing and very pro gay rights,
Trans Rights.
Like there's a,
there's an example of this one woman who's a feminist who said that a woman is
not a man or a man is not a woman.
So like a trans woman who used to be a man and turn into a woman.
Her take is a man is never a woman.
Okay.
And so they told that you got to remove this.
She removed it and then apparently took a screenshot of it and posted it up
again.
She was like,
okay,
I'll delete that.
And she took a screenshot and then posted it again,
like,
fuck you.
And so then they banned there for life and now she's suing that woman.
Megan,
what is her name?
Um,
I forget her.
I got it right here because someone just sent me something to Sam Harris just
sent me something about it today.
Um,
her name is,
uh,
Megan Murphy.
So she's a feminist and she's just like,
look,
you can't just become a woman.
Fuck off.
Nope.
And so they're like,
you're banned for life.
And then everybody's like,
well,
you're crazy.
You can't banner,
which she's got an opinion.
How come she can't have that opinion?
Like if that's a biological opinion,
I mean it might be controversial,
it might be rude,
it might be insensitive,
but it's the same process.
Joe Is the same thing that I lived in Brazil is like it's the sponsor doesn't
want you to say that.
How can you argue it?
I don't think that's a sponsor issue because this is Twitter because I don't
think that's a sponsor.
Sure.
I think this is a left weaning corporation was decided bald.
Okay.
They've decided to censor certain type of speech that they think is offensive
and she was apparently saying it to the person who was a trans person.
Like a a man is never a woman.
And by saying that to the Trans Person,
they're saying that and it was like targeted harassment.
But don't you think that the end of the process edis about money because you
think tweeter care that much.
I saw the,
the Twitter guy here for me to look that he cared about Bush,
about,
about uh,
a bold the speech side of things because there are companies,
sole date they have to pay their bills and they have to bring sponsors and even
brands that are more left sided hearing this country.
So cause that's where it's sensitive,
right?
Cause that's where you can,
you can get boycotted there.
I think there's definitely something to what you're saying that,
but I think also,
well yeah,
if you're a CEO of a major corporation like Twitter or something like that,
you are responsible to stockholders.
You're responsible to all the people that work on the board,
the your truck,
your,
if you want to stay CEO,
you got to continue to make more and more money every year.
You got to bring more people to the platform,
make the platform more popular and make more money and in their eyes,
the way to do that and to maximize that is to limit harassment,
limit things to this.
These are our social decisions,
but they're also,
business strategies are two different things together at the same time.
Yeah.
So it's uh,
it's fucking complex.
Manky yeah.
And they don't know what the fuck they're doing.
This is uncharted territory.
No,
there's never been a thing like Twitter before.
There's never been a thing like Facebook before.
We're complete uncharted territory in 2019,
but it's amazing,
man.
It is amazing to see people like you and me creating our own channels.
We are our old ndcs.
Oh yeah.
So we don't have to depend on that that much.
You just,
you'll feel free.
That's when creativity comes up.
That's one.
People are start to be creative.
That's when new stuff that's so it becomes a threat as well.
Well,
when you stop and think about the sheer impact,
like what?
What was the number that our channel Gut in terms of minutes watched?
What was that number?
Looked for shit for the year.
For last year it was 16.1 billion minutes watched.
That's more than every human on the planet watching it a minute.
Think of isn't it crazy?
Way More.
That's more than double every human on the planet watching for a minute.
Fuck yeah.
I guess it has some fans,
but there's not even that.
It's just that's the impact.
The impact of that is insane.
You know,
negative and positive,
pro and con,
all of it.
The whole thing.
It's like the,
the amount of content that gets put out there and the amount of interactions and
the amount of debate that comes from that content.
It's just,
it doesn't make any sense.
And for me,
the only thing I could do is just walk away.
I don't know what the fuck's going on.
I just throw it out there and get the fuck away from it.
You don't read anything,
read Shit.
I couldn't.
You can go,
oh no.
You get caught up in all of it.
You get,
you would get caught up in the negative or maybe even worse,
caught up in the positive people kiss your ass.
You start believing it.
So I just put,
I try to be humble and if there's an overwhelming negative reaction,
I hear about it.
Having to try to adjust and address it and,
and respect the,
I'm in this unique position where I do have this weird sort of a platform.
I'll start with talking about the,
that you thought that you were in that informed to do the Twitter guy.
Yeah.
That's why I brought Tim Poolan because Tim's a good guy.
He's a good friend.
Isabelle and math came in Brazil.
She went there to cover our protests.
Oh really?
Yeah.
No,
he's on legitimate investigative,
independent journalist and a real honorable guy and honest,
intelligent and well informed.
So I knew he was the perfect guy and we're going to do some other things.
He and I,
we got something that's going to blow people away when,
when that happens.
That was good.
Yeah,
it's this,
he sent me a message yesterday.
Oh side that you're going into a row goes.
I was like,
yeah,
yeah.
I can't talk about it right now,
but we've got something cooking that might have changed to the those teams.
Real.
I still don't have to do some things.
There's some things he focused on her kids,
well,
they're in school right now.
See the thing is,
this happens whether in school and then comedy happens whether asleep.
So I have it down to a science.
Yeah.
So what it is is they go to school.
Okay.
I get up with them to AA there.
I take them to school and my wife takes him to school and then I go either work
out either.
I do yoga or lift weights or Jujitsu or whatever in the morning.
Then I come here,
I'm done in the afternoon.
Then I hang out with them until it's time to eat.
We eat dinner and then after dinner they go to bed.
They go to bed like eight o'clock.
I don't do a set until 10 so I leave the house after that and then you know,
I can go there and my wife was happy to get rid of me,
come to the comedy store,
hanging out and then I,
so it works.
I got it down to a science I want to,
that's the life that I want to.
Oh fortunately my wife left while you were talking about that.
If you want to talk about that.
I do.
I don't care cause it's kind of a crazy story.
I actually say this little stages,
the line that flicks.
Oh really?
Yeah.
And my wife left before a cult.
She joined a cult.
He was crazy.
He will ask,
you will ask man.
But it's like one of those self help culture.
Yes.
But it is a cult.
There's a lot of cults.
It's dangerous.
When one person starts telling another person how you must live your life,
these are the principles.
This is what you have to do.
You have to leave your family.
You have to quit your job.
You have to change the way you dress.
You have to change the way you talk.
You have to do this and do that.
When someone tells you that and they get a mass group of people to do things
like that,
it becomes very dangerous sometimes is not that direct.
Sometimes it's just like,
okay.
Uh,
what was difficult is that her cult was teaching her that you got to love
everybody the same,
which is awesome if you think about it.
Jesus did that.
I think it was the only one who did that.
Jesus was the only one who was like,
I don't care.
I'm not going to have kids.
Right?
I'm going to think this prostitute over here.
And that's okay.
That was his life.
And uh,
for my,
uh,
she,
when she got,
when you'll learn that you,
when you were learned at,
you have to love everybody the same.
Why are you going to focus just one man in a marriage and you have to go home
and uh,
you kind of fall,
leave your life to yourself.
Or maybe she didn't love me anymore and I'm fucking blaming the on baby.
That would be the two as what happened.
Some people are very easily influenced,
you know that that is a real,
the real issue.
And I worry about that sometimes when I talk to people cause like some people
say,
hey man,
well they say,
hey,
you changed my life.
I'm like,
listen motherfucker,
I didn't change shit.
You changed your life.
I go,
I don't even know yet.
I did not change your life.
Don't listen to me.
All I'm doing is talking to a bunch of people.
All of these people have something to offer.
Everyone has something to offer,
but it's not me.
I'm an antenna.
Okay,
I'm,
I'm in a,
if I'm saying something that resonates with you and it helps you,
I'm very happy but don't listen to me.
Like I know everything I think is awesome that you're doing that.
But because you know the power that is half and how you could actually influence
a being flinched in their lives,
in the band.
Very careful of people that do tell you that they have the answers and they're
the one and they're the smart ones and you need to listen to them because that
those people are fucking dangerous because they can get you to do things that
are irreversible.
They can get you to leave your family,
they can get you to,
you know,
to join this fucking commune and give up all your worldly belongings.
And you realize years later where they're fucking crazy.
Like that wild,
wild country documentary that we were talking about us crazy.
They didn't really,
I mean these people were the Hollywood fucking executives and producers,
millionaires know people that look like on paper,
they have their life in order and they want to go and where the red clothes and
the beads and,
and,
and be a part of this fucking movement.
People need a reason to leave.
People need explanation for things that they cannot explain.
And when there's someone that had no thinks that they know the answers,
they can,
uh,
they can lie because it's the easiest.
It's now going to have someone that is going to save if it's true or not.
Yeah.
That's also the danger of a platform and that's the danger of something like
even this podcast,
the danger of any platform.
Anytime we have one person that's talking in front of a microphone and everyone
else is listening,
it's a,
it's,
it's a weird position to be in and you hear this person through your ear phones
or through your computer screen and you start thinking that,
that they're making sense and that they're right because there's no one to
counter what they're saying in front of them.
There's no one with opposing opinions.
There's no one and you,
you,
you can get written,
they can get wrapped up in this position of being a leader as well.
People get intoxicated by being a leader,
you know,
being a,
I mean I,
I've seen it with people that just teach martial arts.
A lot of martial arts classes turn into like very cult like places.
I noticed that,
especially before the UFC came around because everyone really legitimately
believe that their martial arts instructor could kill everyone on the planet.
Everyone really believed that and they'll like the eighties and the nineties and
rice,
they should them that it was not through voice,
always crazy change the fucking world.
He really did.
He changed the whole world and he changed our perception of what martial arts
are and what's effective and what's not.
But before that,
I mean,
I grew up in a taekwondo school,
which was very disciplined in everything everyone was sir,
like a,
you would call everyone Mr. Smith or you know Mr O'malley,
everyone.
Mr. Kim.
Yes sir.
If someone said something to me,
I would always say yes sir.
Yes sir.
And it was always bowing.
It was very strict and very disciplined.
And I came from a very good school,
but I was around a lot of schools that weren't good.
I saw a lot of very cult like behavior.
There was a lot of men who would take advantage sexually of their students and
they would,
you know,
they would do weird shit to their students and they would be almost like running
a little sex cult.
It was a lot of were talking about your stroke or
karate school across schools.
Kung Fu schools.
That's crazy.
We all knew about that.
And some of them wound up going to jail.
I knew,
I knew guys that went to jail.
They went to jail for rape.
Yeah.
And they,
there was people that like,
they were in these positions of power where their students looked at them like a
god and they took advantage of it.
And this is,
uh,
this is the same thing.
It's the same thing as what we're talking about here.
When one person has too much power and influence in a platform,
one of the beautiful things about your Jitsu is it's in formality.
Like when,
like my instructor John Jacques Machado,
he's the friendliest,
nicest guy.
He's a world champion.
I mean,
he's super respected by all,
but when you meet him,
he's like,
hey,
how are you?
It's all hugs and claps and he doesn't ever pretend to be any of the,
any roles with everybody trains with everyone.
So it's like the in formality and the brothership and Camaraderie and the family
environment that is fostered by Brazilian Jujitsu is a very unique in martial
arts and that I think is very important because the respect comes from their,
their ability and from leading by example,
it come from some fake position of being some master of the death touch in some
all knowing person who at the top of the mountain.
We all thought our instructor could kill everyone on the planet.
We really did.
And when the UFC came along,
for a lot of people that was a just a bucket of cold water thrown in your face.
Like,
Whoa,
that little skinny guy just choked out.
All those big giant people like what the fuck man.
So
I mean,
they weren't doing that for a long time in Brazil and beaches and going to
houses and they're going to gyms and just kicking
people's faces.
I fucking,
I don't care.
Yeah.
I mean,
look,
they changed what martial arts are.
They really did.
They boiled it down to what's most effective and they,
they took ground fighting and they turned it into this perfect sort of blend of
leverage and technique and knowledge and repetition and training and,
and they just,
they revolutionized joint manipulation and strangling people.
They revolutionized it.
They changed it to two.
It's a totally different thing.
There was always submissions in judo.
There was always catch wrestling,
which not a lot of great submissions that are still to this day,
but to put it all together like,
like Leo did and Carlos and all the Gracie clan.
I mean,
what Brazil did for martial arts is probably one of the single most significant
things that's happened in the thousands of years of people fighting each other.
Pretty amazing,
pretty amazing.
But at the same time,
that was those guys who shoot your box,
just fucking eat and I shit out of each other.
I then this shit out of each other.
There was an article that I read recently where a vendor Larry was talking
about,
um,
the,
he always,
he's having difficulty now because you know,
he's had so many wars.
He fought for so many years and that he went to some sort of a conference on a
concussions and CTE and he had 13 of the 15 symptoms.
Wow.
Yeah.
And he was talking about,
I forgets things is,
he's impulsive,
all these different symptoms yet.
And then the very next thing he said is,
but I want to fight Vito Belfort.
He's make it fun.
The lace crazy.
He went to my dog show and he's crazy.
He decided not to go like two minutes before he goes and has changed his mind
and he's sweet,
but at the same time,
his right wing now,
he was just,
he tried to go,
he became a politician.
Really.
He went to be a lack that,
but no,
nobody voted.
And who just liked him?
People didn't,
no one can you see on like Congress or so that's good.
Brazil gets it in America.
It's dangerous.
It happens in Brazil to have celebrities.
One of our,
one of our,
uh,
one of our most famous congressman's,
it was a big brother.
Oh No,
that was a big brother and big brother shows so ridiculous.
He has the worst way to become a celebrity.
One of the most watched shows in Brazil.
That's crazy.
I know people that much he had to do.
They don't know anymore.
They still think so for sure.
The crazy thing was Amarosa Amarosa who was one of the big,
she was a,
a big stash was the White House brand is before that she was on fear factor.
I when I was the host,
I didn't know I had a fucking altercation with her on fear factor.
Not a bad one,
but she keeps me being drunk.
She was like,
cause I was asking her questions like that doesn't make sense.
She was choked.
You're drunk.
I'm like,
I'm not drunk or you can't just say I'm drunk.
She wasn't even thinking of this fear before the apprentice.
No,
she was on something else first before the apprentice.
I think that was it.
Was she on the apprentice and then fear factor come on.
Was fear factor before the apprentice the same time.
Just before she got famous for being on the apprentice.
She was on like the second season maybe.
Yeah,
I really did.
I think she was on another show first and then the apprentice,
she went to another reality show after dip brand is,
I don't know who I remember that.
Yeah,
I bought,
the crazy thing is she went from the White House to big brother because she was
actually on the first season of the apprentice.
Oh,
what year was that?
Uh,
so she was on celebrity fear factor.
We had a three to four.
Three.
Okay.
So she must've been on fear factor like 2005.
Eh,
she's nice though.
She's just,
but she was just told me I was drunk.
I was like,
what?
She wasn't elected.
Right.
She wasn't like she was appointed by Trump,
but Trump gave,
so here's what's fucked up.
Here's what's really,
I was reading an article about the,
what the problems with what she did when she was in the situation room and these
secured White House rooms.
She had her fucking phone recording.
So she's sitting there recording shit in the middle of these,
these like totally secure rooms.
She's like,
Trump is talking,
she's got her phone there.
Hmm.
Interesting.
And she's recording everything on her fucking fault.
And she has like hours and hours of footage of record recordings rather,
which you're not supposed to do.
It's like you can literally Russians and Chinese and the Iranians and all the
anybody that wants to tune in could hack into her fucking phone,
turn the microphone on and this is absolute proven technology and they're using
that to listen in the middle of the situation room.
So if there's some sort of top secret shit that's going on,
some foreign entity could be listening in through her phone while she's
recording.
I don't think they see the ignorant.
I think they need all of that.
There's just called Trump and ask what happened?
They'll tell you if like what happened.
I'm like,
okay.
But I mean he's,
he allowed her this,
you know,
I don't know if she's unstable,
but she seems a little unstable to,
that's a such a very dangerous thing to do.
You're not even supposed to bring your fucking phone in those rooms and for her
to be recording,
recording everything.
That's crazy.
This is so crazy,
but so selfish to like if you are acting in the best,
you're in a position when you work for the White House,
you're working for Donald Trump.
He is the president of the United States,
the biggest super power in the fucking world and you're just recording things.
God,
I know that you want to serve yourself.
I know you want to help yourself out,
but God,
that seems so crazy.
I mean if you were trumping,
you hired her and you found out she was recording everything in the situation
room,
you must be like,
oh,
like in conferences with like they're talking about important policy and she's
got a phone recording and anybody can be listening and if you think about it
like it's crazy for him to,
to give her some some credibility because she wasn't apprentice.
He liked,
I didn't think about it.
Okay.
The president of the United States is the guys that was running a premise.
He liked her.
Maybe I'll look.
She's very articulate.
She's good looking woman.
She knows how to speak well.
She's got a lot of confidence and power.
He probably figured she'd be a great politician.
Perfect.
I'm a great politician.
He's probably like,
I'm the fucking president.
I'll make her,
she'll say she's going to be my left hand lady or right hand lady.
And it's not that it that difficult,
but at least in Brazil is not that difficult for our famous people to get
elected in the one day where I was running for a congressman because there's so
many options and if you are known and you'll get like 1% of the voting,
you're already elected.
But if you go run for like a mayor or governor or glove and there are some,
he becomes a little trickier because there's like five options and now you're
running against real politics,
real politicians who actually have a plan.
So we feel running out guys like 200 people.
You can shine Oviedo because you're famous.
Yeah.
We're starting to see a little bit more than America.
Like Cynthia Nixon.
She was on sex in the city and then she ran for which he ran for governor in New
York,
right?
Oh yeah.
Go for it.
Yeah.
So this,
there's a few that few that are starting to branch off into politics now.
It's,
I mean,
did it happen before Ronald Reagan because he was like,
yeah,
he's famous.
He's the most famous,
he,
I think he was a movie star.
He was a big bang,
right?
Yeah.
He was the first guy back to the future.
You mean like Ronald Reagan,
the movie star and like,
yeah.
Yeah.
That was a,
that was the first.
He was the first,
he was also the first that introduced the option or his,
his cabinet was the first.
They got the people that his,
his team got the people from the religious right.
Involved.
Religion was not really a big part of voting before Ronald Reagan and Ronald
Reagan.
And though that sort of kind of Republican,
they got all these event gelical Christians and evangelicals.
Yeah.
And the same thing,
Brazil,
what is going on with Brazil now with your president?
Yeah,
there's a huge connection between politics and the church right now.
The genetical and it wasn't that way before.
He was a little bit,
he was always something because Brazil is a very evangelical country.
Right.
I don't really feel have a wash.
Luckily we were watching it the middle of the night,
they do turn on your TV and there's this guy talking to,
he was like,
oh,
there's a demon that is running over my soul.
And there's
like those TV shows called stop suffering by the Sofrito is more like for those
of the [inaudible].
This church is everywhere.
So EDC,
Joel Olsteen in America,
he's a big time of evangelical Christian.
He sells out these giant arenas,
like 50,000 pizzas.
Come to see him.
Yes,
yes.
Yeah.
But he's very,
uh,
it's,
it's huge in Brazil and they have like,
I don't know,
40% of the people is evangelical in Brazil.
I don't have the numbers right now,
but the church,
the religious,
something huge over there.
So,
uh,
he was something,
that's why we didn't evolve in a lot of different discussions.
Like talking about abortion is now legal in Brazil.
Not Legal at all.
No,
they got all.
Wow.
Just if you're raped,
Jesse,
if you raped or if your kid has like a deformity deformity,
then you can have an abortion.
The woman's life is threatened.
He had a bird.
That's the only cases.
And that discussion was never,
never happened because everybody's religious.
If you do like a,
how do you say when you go public and you ask something to the people,
like,
do you have this here?
It's just like you have a kind of a test.
We have this in Brazil.
Uh,
I don't know how to say this in English,
but test.
Yeah,
it's just a test.
Are you against abortion or pole?
A pole pole.
Okay.
Like an opinion poll.
My second language.
So sometimes me miss a word or two.
I said that's my only language.
So if you do a poll in Brazil,
people would be against abortion.
Like he's the legalization of abortion and against drugs like sex and drugs and
everything.
I what about um,
morning after pill?
Uh,
now it is.
You can take that.
You can't take that.
I Dunno.
I bought some,
so I did it in pharmacy.
So it's okay.
I think the,
I dunno,
but you can,
a abortion is not legal members,
right.
So we are not having that discussion because now the precedence is connected to
the church.
Our ex-president called Lula,
he's in jail right now.
He's in jail,
was in jail.
He was involved in the huge corruption scandal scandal.
And he was like our hope cause he was a poor guy.
So he was a government that actually help the poor in Brazil.
What happened with him?
What was,
he was involved the,
he,
he had connections with different companies and different,
uh,
industries was giving him money and they have this thing called Casha.
Dubois is when you're doing your campaign,
you need to say how much money you're getting from all those different brands
and everything.
So there's thing called [inaudible],
which is you money.
It was spend the money.
There's never went on any banks or anything like that.
So it's kind of a u high,
that money that will had,
that happens a lot in Brazil.
I don't know how to say this in English,
but it's something that you hide the money that you're getting for a company,
but if you get elected,
you kind of forgive them favors.
You'll help them to get like a involved in a construct,
in a huge construction.
They are going to build a stadium.
Then you help them somehow.
That was what happened in,
in Brazil.
So he's in jail now.
He's in jail and then he,
he elected a woman in Brazil and she was impeached.
Oh.
And now we have this right wing guy called Bull Sonato.
He's our new president and a a very right wing and connected to the army and
connected to the church.
So there's a lot of discussions and abortion and drugs and everything that we
are not going to have Susie popular.
He's,
he's,
yeah.
Is he popular and also like hated emails on a lot as well.
Yeah,
of course.
There's the left hate the guy.
It does things that he's sad.
He was like,
he was kind of crazy.
But you're not people.
People love you.
And how long has he been the president of?
He was going to be for 40 years,
so he was just selected.
He started January.
Okay.
Just started,
you know,
we don't know what this is going to lead us,
but the thing is at the same time he's more liberal because the left in Brazil,
all this talk about feeding off speech and everything else was in our left was
running the country.
Now we got this guy and he is more Libero and even talking about the way he's
going to run the country,
the economy and politics and speech and everything else.
So there's a little hope in their areas as well.
So it's kind of tricky because it's a danger in one area and it's kind of a hope
in another one.
I wish I was saying this in Portuguese.
It will be so much easier,
you know,
even imagine can understand cause it's like an understanding.
Well listen brother,
um,
let's do a show together,
my friend anytime.
Listen,
I'm doing a lot of shows at the Improv,
the comedy store.
I'll have you on one of the things from my friend.
I was going to be what I want to see.
Little show it to you.
That's cool.
And I just want to say thank you for everything you've done for standing up in
Brazil.
I think that's amazing.
Thanks.
Thanks for doing this.
Thank you,
man.
Thank you very,
very much for all right.
Thank you.
We'll talk soon.
Bye.